une production du studio sf mais venus
sans filtre le podcast où on parle de ce
qu'on veut avec nos invités dati
ci-dessus ph quentin pas avec moi
aujourd'hui d'une plante bonnes années
2020 la gagne j'espère que 2020 sera
l'auteur de vos ambitions quelque chose
que j'essaie de faire qu'un cache une
rétrospective de l'année qui vient de
terminer ce n'est pas comparer mes
accomplissements à ceux des autres de
comparer mes accomplissements à ce que
je m'étais fixé est ce que je suis
devenu une meilleure personne à ce que
j'ai atteint mes objectifs
si woods lesquels sont les suivants
sinon qu'est-ce que je peux faire pour
les atteindre cette fois ci et je vous
souhaite de faire la même chose parce
qu'à se comparant se comparer en fait je
trouve c'est de plus en plus nocifs
puis j'ai l'impression que que c'est pas
ce qu'il faut faire mais vous faites ce
que vous voulez ceci étant dit parlant
de croissance personnelle
aujourd'hui au podcast on a reçu jérémy
demay jérémy demay vous le connaissez
pour être un humoriste vous connaissez
pour être un auteur à un énorme succès
on a parlé de la façon de voir la vie
géré mexicain qui réfléchit beaucoup à
la nature de l'humain qui essaie de
s'améliorer un voyant les méthodes
alternatives si on veut on a parlé de
tout ce cheminement là il nous a raconté
son expérience avec la technique de
respiration de wim hoste ledit iceman
qui a peut-être vous avez entendu parler
sinon seul en entendent parler pense pas
de cas si on était d'accord souvent en
désaccord parfois mouche x une
conversation qui résonnait beaucoup en
moi parce que j'essaie de trouver des
façons au quotidien réduire le stress
l'anxiété qui souhaitent un fléau
je pense de notre génération est aussi
des générations avant nous et les
générations qui vont nous suivre
principalement liée à la pression des
médias sociaux
c'est pour la première fois qu'on en
parle je crois que c'est un sujet qui
est extrêmement important à aborder donc
moi c'est quelque chose que je cherche
au quotidien puis raconte jérémy momie
sur de bonnes pistes
donc écoutez je vais pas m'attarder
encore à parler la conversation qu'ont
eus je vous demander comme résolution
2020 si vous l'avez pas encore fait
abonnez vous à nos chaînes les seniors i
tin si vous écoutez sur audio les
signaux des commentaires participez à la
discussion on essaie de lire vos
commentaires on essaie de répondre le
plus possible l on est un petit peu
absolument le temps des fêtes
fake j'espère que vous allez apprécier
la conversation avec jérémy donc bonne
écoute et bonbons
[Musique]
ouais mais ça c'est une bonne façon de
ce qu'on disait on va finir la
discussion qu'on pensait aux rondes que
le show business si tu commences en
faisant quelque chose que tu aimes faire
sans que ça te rapporte de l'argent
juste parce que tu aimes le fond ça se
peut qu éventuellement parce que ce que
tu fais ça motive ça donne envie de
continuer ça se peut qu'elle du monde
après ceux qui remarquent face à eybens
là on va le monétiser puis tant mieux
mais ça devrait pas être le point
central du pourquoi tu le fais tu mènes
réputé celle reiss était capable de
l'agencé la chose que tu aimes le plus
fort au monde avec qui monétise soldats
italiens l'excès
que demander de plus finalement c'était
génial c'est génial vous parler à des
gens et vous arrivez à vivre de ça être
payés pour ça c'est pas génial
moi je trouve à fait je trouve le
concept hallucinant il y en a il
travaille fort mais ils vont à l'usiné
moi je suis ta les harangues à raglan
raglan radio dans le nord du québec
ouais déjà ils partent six mois par
année pour aller creuser il travaille
fort fort fort ils voient pas leurs
familles pendant six mois et ils sont
payés bien mais je veux dire à quel prix
pendant que des fois il ya des artistes
qui font ce qu'ils aiment et on fait
payer des fois le concept d comme
hallucinant mais c'est quoi pour toi
jérémy ouais c'est des blagues mais
c'est facile on a des fois je suis
fasciné par sa taille travail il ya des
médecins et des gens ils les ouvrent des
coeurs ils travaillent 24 heures par
jour et ils sont bien payés mais métal
et humoriste qui font des documents cela
et qui sont payés autant ou burlesque
mais étudie c'est ça c'est leur métier
de finalement être soit finalement ça
revient à quai ce qu'est ce que j'aime
je vais le faire j'ai du talent mais les
gens qui vont suivre tout ça fascinant à
il faut se rappeler parce qu'ils étaient
tous médecine même même qu'à sept ans
mais ses drives défaite des jo ne
s'attendent pas des journées d'été à
nîmes et c'est comme acquis non je
raconte des blagues ou je fais de la
musique celle ci où je parle je pense
justement à luzy nous dans la mine de
s'attaquer
et puis ça encourage les gens surtout je
trouve à suivre leur coeur certes il a
l'air simple mais pourtant avoir le
courage de suivre son coeur est donc
entier sait que dans le coeur ce
courageux ça c'est bon c'est vraiment
pas donné à tout le monde ça prend du
gatt suivre son coeur je remarque qu'il
ya beaucoup de gens disent moi j'aurais
aimé faire 6
mfr ça finalement faire autre chose
parce que parce qu'il faut de l'argent
parce que j'ai une famille à nourrir
parce que et avoir le courage de suivre
son coeur c'est pas donné à tout le
monde et tu as raison c'est compliqué
mais quand tu le fais des choses
extraordinaires j'ai rencontré un gars
y'a pas longtemps j'étais à montreux et
pour le festival de montreux en suisse
et je me suis mis à me avec un court de
tennis et moi je connais rien si vous
connaissez j'ai vu j'ai vu sur ton fils
est à graver une photo de toi
dj aucune de ces techniques jeunesse et
stanislav wawrinka marine kaki genre 15e
mondial a gagné de grand chelem et moi
j'y connais rien en tennis et c'est un
ami un ami il y à jeanne ami à moi qui
est champion de tennis
viens on va boire un verre manger au
clean dis moi j'y connais rien moi je
connais djokovic pete sampras
nadal est pas mal mon champ de tête est
pas loin elle est marquée jusque là 4e
ses luttes et finalement il me présente
son pote et on sympathise il fait preuve
pendant la soirée qui libye ni moi dans
la vie fut vite je vais pas le dire que
dans le monde du tennis
ça c'est parce qu'il m'a dit vas-y mais
ville et où vit sa sexualité soit libre
ça ne fait pas tout ça et puis
finalement on fumait un peu je suis un
peu moi je suis rarement dans la vie et
finalement je suis un peu éméché et à la
fin de la soirée
jeudi il faut absolument qu'on fait ce
time avec barrette ce qu'alex bar est un
fan fini est en fait entre temps entre
temps on me dit que c'est une blague qui
m'a fait une blague mais que vu que
j'étais un peu gelé
ben je m'en suis pas rendu compte mais
lui c'est pas que je sais c'est que je
deviens faut qu'on fait c'est mon ami
alex barrette il va capoter si les fans
de tennis moi je connais pas l'impact a
obtenu
mais si un ami qui est moyennement fans
dignité qu'ils voient ça va être elle
même jouer à haut niveau car et au
tennis sait pas où il a joué dur mais je
sais pas à quel niveau par exemple il
l'a dit souvent puis comme il pas
intéressant j'oublie sq oui dont il est
très fort en fait il est encore très
fort et je pense qu'il aurait rêvé de
jouer à un niveau pro c'est le rêve
c'est le rêve et je me dis attention le
festa millevaches yaté c'est sûr et je
fais ce tamedia l'express témoin jugé le
texte
petit festin mois maintenant tp je
trouve maintenant dur externe dans le
hall de l'hôtel
ce qui donne au même hôtel que nous et
je dis festa mois maintenant et il fait
style j'écoute je vais acheter autant de
parler mais faut que je monte mon
nouveau meilleur ami et la jeune stan
écoute on aurait dit un enfant de 4 ans
devant le tas on aurait dit je suis de
12 ans devant justin bieber qui rend
dans son salon non non ben non mais d'un
mécanisme stan wawrinka meilleur ami
tout ça est entre-temps moi j'ai appris
que diesel réclamé j'ai pas dit mais je
commence à aller faire des bisous sur la
joue je commence à embrasser
ça y est on est en couple mais lui sait
pas que de sept enfants j'aime être mal
à l'aise
j'aime être avec amman pourquoi et
pourquoi pas finalement on s'est
finalement s'explique on parle
évidemment je passe vite ça c'est un jeu
on se couche
l'amant se réveille et aux petits jeunes
et lui on recommence à humaniser comme
ça j'en en disant vie ce qui touche la
cuisse lourd mais qui va qui va craquer
c'est un délire ddt romecki le faire
craquer en latin et toilettes entraîne
la personne près du lac je lui ai dit je
te préviens je vais me battre à ce jeu
là je préviens je le bats support et dit
tu comprends pas je suis un champion
sait comment ça j'ai un champion j'ai un
mental d'acier
si tu me mets un défi y a personne qui
me bat mais j'ai un mental d'acier
maintenant je suis capable de battre
fait toute la journée on a poussé et on
imaginer jusqu'où ça peut aller qu'en
2005 il n'avait imaginé la scène dégâts
trop orgueilleux tu vois chevalier tu
vois je te l'avais dit aux deux jeux à
zéro m'ont investi 1
c'est un grand chelem ça non parce que
l'image il pas envie d'aller là parce
que je suis pas gay mais je suis prêt à
aller là pour ne pas perdre pour ne pas
perdre donc toute la journée on s'amuse
on signe est comme ça et puis tout le
monde pense qu'on est guy à
montreux environ on n'aurait pas de sens
et à côté un run et je sors de scène il
m'embrasse wabush thibout de langues o
maintenant il va loin et là je veux dire
rapprocher rapidement parce que je n'ai
c'est que j'ai aucune idée aucune vis de
l'emploi aux galas sac émerveillé et le
soir même on est devant sa mère sa mère
vient loire ce qui donne un numéro avec
mon ami qui s'appelle kev adams cani
maurice français et les besoins numéro
en fait il faisait un duo ce que lui les
suisses il est tout drôle stan n'ont ils
pas drôle mais c'est l'enfant chéri du
pays avec ruby federer et donc il vient
en faire un duo avec kate qui sont amis
et futurs
et il fait son numéro et enfin de seine
et là on va manger ensemble il ya sa
mère et sa mère je dis madame
asseyez-vous on a qu'une chose à vous
dire
mais sa mère elle pas au courant la
porte pas que c'est une blague donc on
vraiment faire croire à sa mère que ce
son fils est lié ok on a une histoire
lui et moi tout ça et là je me dis il a
craqué je viens de trouver la faille
pour faire craquer mon champion sa maman
il commence à me caresser devant sa mère
mais des cars et c'est bien 5 tient ses
crises j'ai dit ça y est tu as gagné
j'avais justement tu vois pas de battre
on est devant ta mère et tim caresse je
rêve pas je voulais pas mettre sa je
sais qu'on va gagner
j'arrête et là j'ai compris ce jour là
que je pouvais pas battre un champion on
est dans sa mère me dit va craquer et il
craque pas et voilà et ça a fait que
c'est vrai que devant sa mère était plus
fort que lui je craquerais pas capable
je suis né pour avoir un mental d'acier
c'est c'est la force des champions une
affaire de champion c'est que s'ils
perdent c'est la pire chose qui est
compétitif comme ça c'est la pire chose
il m'a dit j'ai déconnecté les motifs de
mon cerveau
j'ai plus d'émotions quant à ce
moment-là je me dis j'enlève le côté
sentiments j'enlève le tu vois j'en rêve
de ma tête il fait juste l'action sans
attaches et de malaise de et si sa force
et j'ai dit mais c'est quand même la
fois que tu as pleuré par contre parce
que ferais tu connais le crétois pensera
vente à 92 je pense que c'est autant
dans les deux sens il faut que ce soit
tellement fort mind est tellement faux
que ce qui est rien d'autre qui peut
déranger
non c'est imagine d'imaginer un thé dans
un grand chelem ça peut être des cinq
sets en cinq sets sur trois heures juste
un contre un
a juste envoyé une balle puis essayer de
faire craquer l'autre celle qui va
craquer le premier les tennis est
tellement mentales comparables sont
sensibles s'est pas montré de signe de
faiblesse et il faut jouer chaque balle
titre pourrait être le vrai bal de match
le tpiy spread entre 5,06 mais il faut
quand même que tu joues à la dernière
balle comme si comme si c'était la
première et surtout compter dans les
meilleurs du monde est égal aux usa 243e
c'est déjà bien mais côté 15e mondial
qu'il était 4e mondial west ham c'est
quand et quatrième mondial tu as un
mental je pense qu'ils c'est
incompréhensible
pour nous c'est un nombre assez pour
nous mais j'ai vraiment l'impression que
c'est comme les prérequis pour être un
champion nos teams et on sait que le ou
aux trains et un lance armstrong ou 1 ou
1 michael phelps et des compétitifs
maladie c'est certain je vais pas tpiy
plein d'autres facteurs aussi une
génétique incroyable ou si un dévouement
absolument un petit peu de p&o un peu de
pays un coup d'oeil samsung mais c'est
ouais c'est la compétitivité de la
différence - pitois je pense que ce
mettons la dass pas dans le sport parce
que woods perche on a mangé ensemble on
a commencé tout petit puis c'est aux
primaires on n'avait pas une intrigante
et cordes de force une autoroute
sauf que à travers les années si à
chaque jour il y en a un qui veut gagner
plus que l'autre en entraînement puis
qui vous de jouer un petit peu ya les
plus forts parce qu ils égaux il argué
puis le désir d'être la meilleure
versus l'autre même si la génétique
pratique égard parce que t on et des
corsaires non plus ne met en rogne les
compétitif va surpasser de loin le goût
un petit peu moins compétitif le rouge
est apparemment - copies à wendy positif
et ouais mon cas je mangeais j'ai mangé
pendant cinq ans avec les rougeurs de
murcie avant de perdre chaque fois que
j'étais derrière le bloc peu importe
c'est quoi le niveau de la compétition
c'était moi le meilleur dans ma pacte
fait qu'il y avait personne d'autre même
si ça a été depuis que tout petits le
team and cash je me faisais battre je
m'appuyais pas en disant monsieur ben a
priori meilleur que moi
c'est je me suis fait battre par
quelqu'un qui - beaucoup - ah ouais fait
que j'essaie de comprendre qui est long
mais ça fait pas de sens explique que ça
me mettait aussi fâché parce que dans ma
tête j'étais juste le meilleur piste est
comme ça que j'arrivais avec tellement
de confiance derrière les plots de
départ que ma confiance a jamais manqué
de confiance qui dans une course jamais
je suis arrivé un petit peu trop nerveux
ou quoi que ce soit juste parce que dans
ma tête c'était comme ça que ça
fonctionne et si les roulements premier
pour lui tu mets ton stan wawrinka
vraiment pour lui si le meilleur puis
que caen qui perd même si par contre
nadal ou federer
il s'excuse pas la défaite parce qu'ils
sont meilleurs que lui ces a selon lui
prouvant qu'il maillot away est encore
comment ce mental là à toi te sers
aujourd'hui est-ce que tu utilises
encore ouais donc beaucoup c'est vrai
que j'en parlais justement en fin de
semaine avec pete sampras avec [ __ ]
bras avec rodriguez
j'en parlais justement avec andrey
correspondrait mais non c'est ça mais
j'en parlais justement parce qu'en ce
moment
si je me suis lancé en affaires avec ma
copine pour faire des efforts de tous
reagan
ouais cool puis on est dans un espèce de
grosse grosse structure entreprenariale
c'est vraiment on est vraiment comme des
des petits poissons dans l'eau c'est en
ce moment t on parlait de cosco tout à
l'heure le tri c'est vraiment une grosse
machine qui nous ont rendus là dedans
puis dans des conversations business 4
quelqu'un qui vaut 600 millions à sienne
avant toi tu peux pas tu peux pas te
sentir inférieurs parce que tu vas faire
manger tout cru c'est faux que tu as
l'impression de valoir autant que
l'autre personne avec moi dans ma vie
aujourd'hui papa la valeur la personne à
moi que ce soit monétaire ou théo ou un
gars qui grands qui grosse selon moi
j'ai je peux tenir prête à tout le monde
c'est dans ma vie ça fait que dans des
meetings comme ce jeu me fait pas
impressionné je serai bien timide et ça
me permet d'avoir une discussion d'égal
à égal
peu importe avec qui de questions la
première c'est tu dis quoi
quant à devant un gris qui vaut 600
millions ouais et en vo 4 millions mais
quatre pièces
comment ce que tu dis je me dis que que
cette personne-là a pas une valeur
intellectuelle plus haute la mienne puis
je me dis que à valeur intellectuelle
égal c'est sûr que je peux y amener
autant qu'il peut m'amener tout l'argent
qu'il a fait là le développer dans un
contexte de d'entrepreneuriat mais
pendant que ces personnes là mettait du
temps à l'entrepreneuriat et mettait pas
du temps dans autre chose avec moi tu
peux t'en que j'ai mis dans autre chose
je peux aussi apporter à n'importe qui
en savoir que j'ai développé une
expertise que j'ai développées même si
c'est pas une expertise en poutre
entreprenariale fait que j'ai autant
quelque chose à apprendre à n'importe
qui même si pendant son milieu à lui
this way fait que ce jeu mais je me dis
que la valeur qu'on a et pas calculable
parce que il ya beaucoup de choses comme
si un podcast comme seuls les
conversations qu'on a comme en ce moment
le ce on peut pas mettre un chiffre sur
ce message va place de faire sans ce
moment on est en train de monter une
business ou d'essayer de prendre notre
temps pour essayer de créer quelque
chose de monétaire type roman qu'on
réussira le fort d'une certaine à
certains égards peut être pas 600
millions le saas est une réussite
professionnelle énorme et au delà d'une
réussite professionnelle et les
réussites personnelles puis ses deux
enfants dont le mode stand qui ont
autant de valeurs que j'essaie de
compartimenter lisez ces choses là puis
de dévaluer ma pro-bachar selon ce que
moi je crois que je vous le temps est ce
qu'il ya une personne que tu pourrais
rencontrer coutu sentirez impressionné
ce match je me sens impressionné avec
avec toi en ce moment les tiges de s'en
imprégner par des gens qui ont réussi à
faire des grandes choses et que ce soit
artistiquement ou entreprenariale
outillés quoi que ce soit mais je me
sens pas intimidés a donc eu du respect
pour la personne exactement tout à fait
je suis très impressionné par des gens
qui ont un parcours exceptionnel
qui ont réussi dans leur super mais ça
m'intimide pas marqué je comprends ouais
c'est sûr parce que ça vaut beaucoup de
t'inspirer aussitôt déclarée
impressionnée été inspiré par personne
des points samedi tout en priant
ferreira pour août
ok ok ok et attend ça m'intéresse le
véganisme reagan récemment où il ya
longtemps
ça fait
ça va faire deux ennemis bientôt donc
forcément tu as vu le netflix game
schengen tout le monde parle depuis des
semaines ouais hallucinant c'est c'est
fou c'est fou ça l'a été
ça l'était le documentaire et plus
polarisé de tous les documentaires qui
ont été faits sur la question ça y est
je gagne parce que c'est celui qui
frappe le plus proche des croyances des
gens c'est parce que maintenant un
documentaire qui traite de la l'écologie
par rapport aux organismes tout le monde
est conscient de ce tome on est prêt à
accepter cette vérité là mais quand ça
challenge quelque chose qui est aussi
personnel que la façon avec laquelle
tout aliment depuis les traditions et
les croyances qu'on a par rapport à la
nutrition
ça choque beaucoup fait que beaucoup de
réactions mais cc c'est fascinant ce
documentaire
moi j'ai des amis qui sont devenus vegan
depuis ce documentaire à quel point tu
l'as vu j'ai pas encore vu encore
malheureusement même si excellent ça
l'était il ya beaucoup de monde qui ont
essayé de 6,2 répond au documentaire qui
le qui l'accusait de cherry picking donc
de choisir ça sert de la négritude
certaines données faut que tu le fasses
quand tu fais un documentaire tu peux
pas être allé taille était un la
panoplie tu peux pas faire l'argument
est le contre argument dans ton
documentaire qui va dans une direction
le tir mais toutes les faits sont basés
par là son bac et par la science c'est
donc tout ce qui est dit et baky par la
science fait part des consensus
scientifique je trouve ça fascinant puis
je trouve ça excellent que le soleil
briser les stéréotypes que les gens
peuvent pas être en forme
c'est ce que c'est seul point principal
c'est le bruit principal s'est pas
arrêté de manger de la viande ça va vous
tuer la viande posture qui disent oui la
viande pour les maladies coronariennes
c'est moins bon qu'une alimentation
végétale mais ça tout les
nutritionnistes s'entendent pour dire
d'une la viande plus de légumes sur tout
le monde s'entend que ce même pas ce qui
est en débat
pee wee la question de quand moi mais
djokovic et vegan mais en même temps
nadal et les potins je comprends que
peut-être que le meilleur l'est pas mais
ce que ça prouve c'est que ça prouve que
tu peux light avec une fois que tu
prends en considération toutes les
enjeux de l'environnement pour les
enjeux des animaux mettant l'éthique
animale ou l'environnement
si tout vu le devenir ce documentaire le
sert juste à prouver que tu peut le
devenir sans aucun impact sur la santé
il est rare qu'un impact négatif du fait
que c'est que c'est comme ce que le
monde dont j'ai l'impression que vous ne
manquiez dans ce documentaire le parce
qu'il ya plein de gags justement dans
les humoristes qui comptait vegan tu
pars à quelqu'un puis exarque c'est pas
vrai du tout
on pense qu'une fausse croyance qui on
le dit aux gens qui nous écoutent pas ce
que je vais gagner c'est encore assez
mitigé mais les gens disent ouais mais
tu as pris ta protéines faut bien
apprendre à protéger l'animal tu veux
mais tu penses que les animaux ils
apprennent ou leur prêter ses soeurs il
n'est ce pas avec un laps rennes quelque
part et ils apprennent dans les planter
dans les fruits etc et dans un
documentaire l'a vraiment intéressant il
ils disent que les animaux les plus
puissants de la terre sont végétariens
ouais le gorille le buffle le bison le
taureau l'éléphant pour tous des animaux
végétariens et surtout sony mots les
plus puissants - william mériel lyon
puel guépard qui sont très puissants
mais reste que ces animaux là qui ne
mange jamais de viande sont extrêmement
puissants donc ça te montrent que
finalement tu vois des gars dans ce
document interne à qui sont énormes qui
vont aux jeans qui sont énormes qu'ils
mangent pas de viande
tu vois le gars qui fait de l'accord
d'abandon il explique comment s'appelle
ce gala café documentaire
le gars qui fait qu'on vole james est un
ancien champion de combat ultime essai
james wilkie super coville est donc je
me trompe pas why a gagné le tmt fighter
qui était quand même comme un peu
l'équivalent de la voix pour le combat
ultime hockey fait qu'à ce moment là
c'était comme le open comme heures avant
qu'ils se blessent
ok c'était lui qu'elle ait comme next
big thing dans l'ufc
finalement il aurait enfin beloeil
commence à faire son intéressant ce qui
a commencé à enseigner la défense aux
militaires puis aux policiers défense et
l'autodéfense warhol puis puisqu'il
s'est intéressé à ce que j'ai décidé de
devenir un activiste pour la cause le
gagne ouais pivot jim et au jimmy un
tableau avec et pour les cordes c'est
les exercices de crossfit le psychopathe
il dit ils montent ce qu'on peut faire
plus d'1 minute plus de 30 minutes plus
tard en minute il le fait et depuis que
je vais gagner beaucoup plus fort il va
au dessus d'une heure oui et c'est le
seul à avoir fait autant et j'aurais pu
continuer ça c'est depuis que je m'en
juste des plantes et des fruits des
légumes et des tu vois que ça montre à
quel point il ya vraiment quelque chose
de francs là dedans ils prennent des
pompiers ça ils prennent les pompiers
ils prennent leur cholestérol
tous ces gens qui mangent de la viande
du poisson etc ils leur disent pendant
une semaine
arrêtez de manger de la viande
complètement manger des fruits des
légumes etc ils le font et leur taux de
cholestérol diminue drastiquement
il prouve vraiment par a plus b qui est
vraiment un impact assez et tous les
gens qui sont venus qui lui sont en très
bonne santé
ben moi moi c'est ça à 100 % de ces
jeunes sortir un blog sur notre site web
ou un site web qui s'appelle vegan n'est
pas plate parce qu'on écrit des articles
de blog qui et puis moi c'était mon
expérience à moi par rapport au
bannissement le sport et puis je peux
pas comparer avec moi quand j'étais en
condition physique
ultime qui achetaient mettons quand
j'étais nageurs universitaire que je
m'entraînais 25 à barcelone parce que je
le fais juste plus fait que je peux pas
être plus en forme que prépare ma
nutrition qui quand je mangeais 25 mai
de toute évidence j'ai des bénéfices je
peux pas les peut pas scientifiquement
les expliquer j'ai pour cette formation
là je prépare je prétends pas l'avoir
non plus mais au niveau de la
récupération c'est la chose qui me saute
aux yeux
j'ai plus de courbatures away
pratiquement plus de courbatures
je vaux jim tu fais les entraînements
cas actuellement pendant deux jours je
regarde déplier l'hébreu j'ai pu de
courbatures pratiquement pu puis quand
j'en ai déjà beaucoup moins longtemps
puis je peux mettre étape
je peux juste à quai les entraînements
chaque jour 5 mon corps c'est comme ça
que j'ai fait est que je me suis
entraîné au marathon cet été j'ai fait
un bon match j'ai fait 3h15 marathon
québec c'est bon je n'arrivais camp 69e
sur comme 2000 personnes 1000 quelques
personnes puis je pas un coureur c'est
juste que j'étais capable à chaque jour
d'aller cours et 100 blessés ah oui puis
des vingt kilos dé 25 kg à vide et même
des fois des 35 tipi à chaque jour en
répétition des semaines à plus de 100 kg
pis je récupérerai vraiment mais c'est
la chose qui vous ont marqué ah ouais
puis je me suis entraîné avant dans ma
vie c'est comme si je connaissais pas
sur le dessus je connais mon corps je
connais comment je me sens puisque c'est
vraiment un plus vraiment vraiment et
puis disons plus t'as vu lewis hamilton
et diane dufresne et guérir et vegan y
arriver j'ai choisi des ivg
avec ce qui déjà ce que j'ai super mal
oui tout à fait et en fait se rend
compte que la viande non halal isla
l'est est très lent très longue date
l'aide vegan men et je te rends compte
que ça ne manque pas en fait qu'on
arrête d'en manger
pas du tout non pas puis surtout le moi
je prends de l'argument que j'avais pas
ses skis ski ce qui pollue plus c'est sa
brusque les boîtes jaunes plus qui
voiture plus les bateaux puissants et
n'importe quoi c'est les animaux ouais
et toute l'eau qu'on consomme pour
pouvoir entretenir et tuer des animaux
c'est absolument énorme
oui ça quand tu vois si tu as roi ok
alors ça je pense que c'est soutenu non
c'est vrai nom c'est pas tout ça c'est
100% vrai le problème est que le
documentaire avec game center c'est pas
que les statistiques sont pas backé par
la science parce que c'est leur source
de toutes les statistiques
le problème c'est qu'ils choisissent les
quelles limites de l'avant c'est par
exemple je vais donner l'exemple de on
peut être super performant avec une
diète végétarienne
on peut sans doute aussi être super
performant avec une diète omnivore bien
balancé tu y mets encore là beaucoup
moins de viande puisque le monde
consomme en général avec beaucoup plus
de végétaux mais évidemment ils vont pas
prenez ça parce que ce qui prouve s'il
arrêtait complètement pour
l'environnement puis pour la
pour les animaux ont aussi fait que
c'est ce que vont pas dire non mais
continue et en mange un par semaine
notamment jeu quand même par semaine
c'est ça qui me vont ils vont montrer
que tu peux tout faire avec cette
augmentation
le documentaire focus sur l'aspect santé
pour montrer que c'est même pas pour
montrer que ça va être plus en santé
nécessairement il même si c'est ça que
ça démontre là selon ce qui démontre
mais c'est de montrer que tu peux tout
faire ce avec aucun aucun négatif 03 que
tu peux t'on santé sans consommer des
animaux sans consommer des produits
animaux temps à la même santé voire plus
en fait d'un manque de temps cholestérol
diminuerait sait seulement que tu as
plus d'énergie donc tout est plus clair
dans mon esprit faits qui montrent
vraiment gagner des élections sont plus
toujours plus longue des vrais abel de
football ces pousses
ils les font manger et ils leur disant à
comparer des nuits la journée même la
nuit mais dans la nuit même fait raison
il discute et on a des élections la nuit
nous les hommes oui on dort jamais parce
que tu es familier avec ce concept c'est
pas mal matin absolument mais moi je
savais qu'on avait le matin exedra sur
toi qu'on avait autant régulièrement la
nuit précédent documentaire s'achève et
donc ils comparent quand une fois que je
mange de la viande et il ne faut pas
manger de viande ils voient que le
niveau d'action est plus fort et plus
long c'est démesuré le cam à ces
casemates plus en plus longs plus long
non mais il manque le monde la
circonférence du pénis qui a grossi la
journée où est-ce qu'ils ont pas mangées
devient mais non ce jour après jour
chaque semaine c'est vraiment apprécié
c'est que ça non mais oui mais il ya des
éléments dans le documentaire route
était mal à l'aise ou en désaccord vous
n'ont jamais non jamais en désaccord
vraiment c'est le seul retour qui ont
été faits étaient par rapport au fait
que qui omettait certaines informations
par rapport à un dilemme niveau mais le
point c'était pas si c'est le point de
documentaires ce n'est pas de dire oui
mais il ya aussi ce n'est pas de montrer
vous
si toutes les bandes y est pour faire du
sport si ce n'est pas ça c'était voici
cette diète l'appui l'impact est la
lentille puis effectue t bag et par de
la science puisse et james cameron qui a
financé ce film le petit james cameron
et de l'argent à barnard puis l'équipe
de scientifiques
derrière seul à commencer par le
chairman de l'école de nutrition à
harvard qui bac tout souci c'est comme
des consensus scientifique ce qui sait
même pas débat table c'est la force qui
peut même pas de débattre de ça parce
que si tout déborde dessus du débat de
wes carnet la science aujourd'hui fait
que tu peux pas vraiment faire il ya
beaucoup de gens qui j'ai un ami qui a
aimé le commentaire est dit mais
pourquoi je remplace pourquoi je
remplace la viande et le poisson je te
les gardes mais pas plate points comme
85 recettes savoureuses
je vais lui on ne livre de recettes ma
copine et moi et j'en ai nom change de
l'america avec plaisir maintenant
chercher des recettes coach vous
attendez ça mais tu vois ce que tu peux
remplacer par des dépôts chiche ça c'est
les pois chiches celle des pois chiches
le c'est ultra protéines et beaucoup de
fibres cela les filles c'est la clé de
voûte la digestion et comme bien sentir
pas se sentir trop lourd les pois
chiches c'est vraiment qu'à lentilles
pois chiches les mamies dort jamais le
dire et les mêmes amis et de mes rêves
de soyo dans le fond fin de séance et
sur les hommes mais bon tu vois c'est
qu'il ya plein de choses à l'affût et
aussi un débat là-dessus sur le soleil à
ses seuls s'est perpétuée par les
industries de la viande il rien de
crédible dans le fait dans le fond ce
qui le monde s est que le tofu ed
d'estrogènes hockey dans le sol puis
c'est des phytoestrogènes en fait fait
que ça n'a pas du tout le même effet sur
le corps d'accord puis il explique aussi
c'est ce que je comprends c'est
déconcentration pour et à manger 80 et
rock pour qu'il y en ait
c'est ça puis on avait parlé de chemin
avec le pharmacien et c'est ce
qu'expliquait est directement à l'infini
ce fut le cas il ya un moindre problème
ah ouais ouais et c'est de bon ton porte
que ça va comme de faire swinguer les
testicules pinochet dessin
mais jean philippe et jean philippe sol
est un chef de gan d'ici le 6 le tofu
faisait pousser les seins ça coûterait
pour matcher et le gluten secoue le
débat sur gluten hills a rien à voir que
le véganisme c'est sa fin non mais il ya
un risque que c'est mauvais c'était
coeliaque ce réellement seria kit
maladie qui a été peut pas consommer de
gluten fois des effets très néfastes en
santé oui mais ces deux ou trois pour
cent des populations
après ça c'est vraiment pour cent la
population normandie
sinon quelqu'un personne intelligente
soucis mais après si c'est quand même un
team aura sinon le gluten ne pas manger
puis un effet négatif sur la santé
ouais c'est cool qu'on se conscientisent
plus 60 et je trouve ça cool ben tout à
fait du coup c'est plus de notre temps à
nous à nous que tant de nos parents et
la difficulté c'est juste démêler le
vrai du faux parce qu'il y en a beaucoup
et beaucoup de moi de là dedans pis
c'est le problème c'est que de nos jours
les gens travaillent beaucoup de gens
sont très anxieux mais les gens sont
fatigués les gens font des sommes ni les
gens ont tout à deux problèmes de santé
qu'ils sont pratiquement des espérait
trouver des solutions pour leur santé
ils sont curieux aussi s'informent mais
les sources sont peu tout également
c'est très difficile parce que des fois
ça a l'air super crédible sadler super
bon mais parfois si c'est zéro baky
parasciences le flec fac c'est soit des
gens sont en recherche de solutions mais
il ya beaucoup d' attrape nigaud et
beaucoup de gens qui font beaucoup
d'argent sur la crédulité des deux
personnes chez moi je m'intéresse
beaucoup au sujet de la santé physique
et émotionnel et avec ça et je dis
souvent aux gens la meilleure chose
c'est essaye qui a peut-être choses qui
sont bonnes pour moi que sont pas de
bonnes pour toi et c'est le voici une
piste qui te plaît c'est le système bien
génial je t'aime pas art est absolument
sûrs c'est aux français pas d'expérience
mais il faut aussi être être sceptique
peut être à aller aussi voir qu'est ce
qui a été démontré puis qu'est-ce qui
qu'est-ce qui peut démontrer c'est parce
que il ya foule de produits en vente à
la pharmacie où c'est écrit sur la botte
qu'elle est bien fait pour c'est pour ça
mais ça pas été prouvée
en études cliniques puis le jeu par
certains produits alternatifs mettons la
faculté site apprendre ça fait bien tant
mieux mais parfois c'est juste un effet
placebo aussi qui se passe à la limite
siffle c'est vrai pour toi et la
probable le problème avec avec ceux ci
si quelqu'un qui fait de l'argent sur un
effet placebo
ouais ce samedi 16 mai halimi si tout
est fait du bien j'ai trouvé une
solution et finalement on se rend compte
que c'est l'effet placebo m'étais trouvé
une solution à son problème à lui je me
dis pourquoi pas tant que tu va mieux
après oui absolument
c'est bien de d'aller mieux mais c'est
ça mais il y en a qui qui comme ph dit
qu'ils se remplissent les poches avec
avec du vin la vie des pilules a aussi
créé pcc ce qui est un peu problématique
c'est ça que pharmacien du g13 que le
cnc cambo presse pas ah ouais qu'il ya
beaucoup de choses qui sont pas bonnes
pour en fait qu'ils sont notre travail
c'est de faire les fausses croyances
limite qui est d'aller voir justement
ces effets de mode low ses effets de
l'eau puis d'aller voir qu'il est il
réellement quelque chose le conte plus
démontré que pouvait que en études que
si je prends deux groupes
aujourd'hui des placebos ou jordan ce je
vois des effets c'est confirmé le faire
des méthodes d'étude mais il ya beaucoup
de charlatanisme qui est beaucoup d
oxyde m c'est très à la mode des
influenceurs ouais on est soudé où le
n'importe qui peut s'improviser expert
surtout plein domaine puis le domaine de
la santé
ce prix est un domaine où l'objectivité
d'importantes leçons
si on parle de certains sujets le surge
parle de politique ou si je parle de
valeurs aussi je parle de mon histoire
c'est pour ses poses une question
d'opinion mais que l'on parle de centrer
le il faut avoir une démarche
scientifique le tir on n'a pas le choix
après ce type il les leçons de
personnalités qui deviennent déjà de
référence comme ed je pense à des
dégoûts des pôles chaud des universités
comme ceux qui se mettent à vendre des
produits santé en guillemets mais pis
les gens les achètent parce que ces gens
là sont connus mais en réalité est-ce
que ça n'en fait une sommité ce que
c'est en effet un expert dans le domaine
de ce que j'en ai vu quelqu'un qu'on
devrait
coté sur ces sujets là pour plus qu'une
personne c'est plus qu'une personne
des fois la science a pas encore
embarqué aussi tu vois c'est ça la femme
et ça c'est un autre problème étant que
m moi je dis maintenant
fillon nous à ce que la science explique
maintenant puis il ya beaucoup de monde
qui justifie ce genre de truc un peu
ésotérique là avec le fait que ouais
mais la science au pas encore tout
expliquer pis la science et beaucoup
trompé dans le passé une certaine époque
au nom de la science on faisait la ceni
pour fêter le titre des traitements qui
ont commencé mais la science pour la
vérité à tout pour toutes les réponses
mais c'est souvent la réponse la moins
fort ce qu'on aime ou on est rendu au
point qu'on pense que josé way puis des
fois c'est mitigé
je voyais à ça c'est vrai c'est un gars
qui s'appelle wemhoff que des courriels
l iceman d iceman comme ça ouais ses
méthodes de respiration
ouais pas malade pour les gens qui nous
regardent ce gala huawei les éthiques ce
gars-là c'est une france qui les danois
je pense où j'ai pu ou h 15 9
scandinave et qui montrent l'himalaya en
short puis après il va courir un
marathon pieds nus puis il reste sous
l'eau il voit dans l'eau glaciale et
c'est une chose c'est vrai show plus
sexy scientifiquement son corps reste
chaud c'est ça il sait même pas quel
feeling irakien et il dit
il dit grâce à ça tu peux améliorer la
santé considérablement du monde le prend
pour un fou les deux jeux d'eau froide
ouais c'est ça beaucoup de manques
prenait de geoffroy men voilà donc moi
d'ailleurs
tapie cas ça fait eh ben ça fait que au
début quand j'ai commencé à m'entraîner
là dessus
les médecins ont embarqué la science a
embarqué ils lui ont donné raison hier
qu'ils y ont injecté un virus à
l'intérieur de lui qui normalement il
aurait été super malade il a rien eu ils
l'ont mis dans des glaçons dans une
heure et demie et sa température
corporelle n'a pas bougé et que
maintenant la science bac se gagnent sur
un trend de faire des études sur
pourquoi ben en fait ils comprennent que
grâce à la respiration et le froid tu
améliores togo date à condition physique
c'est sage l'explication d'ailleurs il
s'est mis à pleurer jour là il a dit ça
y est enfin je suis plus un fou la
science bac mon propos sauf qu'avant ça
c'était un fou ouais pour beaucoup de
monde donc des fois tu vois des fois
t'es un fou jusqu'au jour où attention à
wind ont finalement ce seuil à il ya six
mois personne par l peu de gens pareils
véganisme d'un couteau que tout le monde
commence à en parler partout game
schengen tout le monde documentaire est
tranquillement les gens commencent à
prendre conscience les nutritionnistes
commence à se faire enseigner aussi
d'aller à l'école ah ouais ouais infecté
ça devient des couacs est la science
aussi peu bac s mais je veux qu'on
revienne aux douches froides presque
comme un taxi je tombe là dessus il ya
c'est quand même temps parce qu'il ya un
an tombe là dessus il ya un an et le
titre de la vidéo sur youtube c'est le
show de code pour le bien-être comme ça
moi je moi je suis âgée j'ai temps à
perdre clic 15 millions dès que 15
millions des coudes cliquer sur ce gars
là est ce gars là explique ça qu'avec un
truc de respiration et le froid ta mère
ta condition physique et moi je suis
hyper curieux de ce genre de choses là
moi tu vois je suis pro bac es pas
marqué par la science on dirait que je
m'en fous que si j'ai un feeling ça
pourrait m'aider
ben je vais l'essayer puis je voir
comment je me sens puis j'aime bien je
continue ici j'aime pas j'arrête car
c'est des choses qui qui qui blesse
personne tant que j'espère sonne fait ça
bien sûr été le seul apte à 2 chez les
personnes qui n'ont en général les trucs
de santé pour moi c'est moi avec moyen
âge tu vois que 2 froide je dirais puis
les risques pour toi sont portés ou pire
ça marche pour pas très grave mais c'est
une maladie grave
c'est le propre camp sara puis les
médecins de suggère-t-elle traitement
qui refusent parce que ton feeling ou
ton instinct me dit moi je crois parce
c'est plus un cool courir des risques
c'est d'être sceptique autant un envers
la science la médecine
huawei puis rallier si les gens veulent
se dire moi
en fait il me dit que non puis après ça
s'améliore où ça devient pire ça allait
me chacun est libre de changer d'idée de
faire ses choix de chacun sa vie tu vois
je fais que je commence ce truc là et au
début c'est étrange ce que je commence à
chercher l'inspiration est vraiment
après ça au tout début quand je t'ai pas
habitués talent est aller respirer dans
la douche
non je respirais avant et après j'ai à
prendre la douche froide et je me
sentais vraiment mais vraiment essayé la
lega énergisé comme s'il avait bu du
café
j'étais vraiment tu vois tu vois le
feeling de gérer pris la cocaïne 7
heures du matin on fait quoi mais alors
pourtant j'ai eu de respirer et j'ai
juste pris une douche ça coûte moins
cher que la cour que ça coûte mois et
donc j'ai trouvé plein de bienfaits à sa
dont un que pour moi le mail aujourd'hui
puis prend un mot en anglais alors que
j'ai pas un bel accent anglais mais
c'est le fait de dire que quand tu rates
dans l'eau froide
mon premier réflexe c'est de commencer à
respirer plus rapidement pourquoi parce
que ton cerveau te dit quitte tu vas
mourir donc l instinct de survie
qu'embarque ça qu'on fait tous tu vois
quand tu attends au froid et donc
pourquoi pas ce que ton cerveau
enregisté en train d'être dans une
station était stressé quitte sa pour
allait survivre et j'ai appris que en
fait y réaliser correction sous la
douche en relation sur le froid et en
calmant ce stress là et bien j'en vois
un nouveau message à mon cerveau je lui
envoie un message qui dit même en
situation de stress tu peux te calmer tu
vois tes pas en train de mourir n'est
pas en train et arriverait en ce moment
c'est calme ça etc en apprenant à calmer
ma respiration et donc ont calmement mon
stress à ce moment là dans une situation
de stress que je mets seul et bien
d'autres situations de la vie où je vis
du stress ça apprend à me calmer et
ajustements pas réagir pu réagir au
stress de dos situations de la vie
c'est une sorte d'entraînement
finalement cet entraînement là me permet
après dans la ville est plus calme plus
posé plus tu vois il m'arrive encore de
stresser je suis pas surhumain mais au
moins je le dis le mieux grâce au froid
et donc mal énergie s'améliore si tu es
stressé ou fatigués ou anxieux ça
diminue tout ça il y a plein plein de
bienfaits il paraît que c'est bon pour
la peau c'est bon pour la fécondité
j'avais lu ça aussi c'est bon pour les
cheveux c'est bon pour il ya plein plein
plein de bienfaits à ça que prouver par
la science moi j'encourage vraiment les
gens à au moins être curieux de ça parce
que c'est gratuit
et tout le monde peut le faire chez eux
tu es chez toi tu fais toi c'est gratuit
il n'y a pas de
plus peu moins cher de est-ce que est
moins malade
moi ça fait un an j'ai rien eu ça fait
1-1 puis ça fait un acte pas été malade
ça fait un an que j'ai pas j'ai
pratiquement aucune grippe aucune non
mais est-ce qu'il ya d'autres composants
et échanger de nouvelles habitudes qui
est encore présente à vie qui pourrait
aussi contribuer à saint louis
ouais ouais bah j'ai mon alimentation
j'ai switché mais j'ai pas devenu
totalement gaga c'est à dire que je suis
vraiment attiré par l'organisme mais je
suis flexible 21 molex tarifs
flexitariens ces 24 heures c'est très
drôle 80% du temps je suis hétéro mais
vos rencontres ajouté lise de l'argent
chez achetable chatah et en fait non
parce que je n'aime pas et chez les amis
puis tu es là tu fais tes gars qui fait
chier non moi j'ai mené ma salade c'est
que j'ai envie aussi de tu vois
apparaître deux pas de chien je tombe je
suis flexitariens par non chantilly mais
sinon 80% du temps 85 % du temps
j'essaye de plus de lait peuvent plus
produire six manades lights un chien
aussi pour être fait à mes côtés je suis
déjà allée nager l'impression que c'est
le même mois
ça fait pas si longtemps sur le pis j'ai
vu une différence dans les six derniers
matchs par six motards
j'ai vu une réelle différence puisque le
monde ne reçoive pis cvg moi sans que je
le mans zack mettons maintenant mais mes
parts et d'amis le mot j'ai un ami qui
nous reçoit à québec avec qui j'ai nagé
à l'université quand on reçoit tout ce
groupe le plus tôt chasseurs puis depuis
que depuis que moi je le suis que j'en
parle un petit peu maintenant il rendu
végétarien à 99% place aux viandes qui
mange ses avions au dessus puis pékin
kim nous reçoit calcaire soient légaux
le groupe d'amis au complet cvg pire
personne qui déçus en bref personne tout
le monde est content de soi
fernand parce que ce tour du monde qui
mange c'est qu'ils mangent végétal
quatre à cinq fois par semaine parce
qu'ils sont conscientisés depuis
dernier la dernière année maintenant
puisque là mais pourquoi ça change quoi
que ce samedi soir le ce soit un des
repas végétal dans la semaine fecteau pu
finir à temps si c'est bon ce que tu
manges tu l'oubli que ça n'a rien à
cacher l'oubli nécessité juste bon sur
le manche c puis moi que moi ça fait un
an je suivais g qui au début justement
j'allais chez mes parents puis ma mère
était presque un pur friterie pis c'est
une religion votre affaire pinana secte
qui vit aujourd'hui chez vos côtés
aujourd'hui à se pose même plus la
question
quand je viens on mange léger puisque
c'est correct tout le monde est content
les personnes qui a marqué frustré de ce
les gens s'habituent
ou sinon pis s'ils mangent pas vg il
faut leur chose puis je fais ma chose à
côté puis chacun manche en assiette puis
il ya personne qui est que des
ressentiments envers personne
enfin quand j'ai mis tellement de
karachi des amis étaient à la longue des
amis le savent le ton tout nouveau
régime alimentaire
puis il s avoue soit justement tu peux
arriver puis ils peuvent plus se voir
des amis de beaucoup moins d'amis ils
ont dû prendre un café avec du lait
d'amande ou dans des restaurants ce qui
est beaucoup d'options c'est juste la
période d'ajustement début quand que six
nouveaux plats le cassis de nouveautés
justement les gens pour ta question cm
et commencer le génialement pourquoi
puis tout comme un petit justifie plutôt
comme un peu cette discussion le il faut
que tu le eu une fois ou deux fois avec
ce même après ces régles moi je connais
les gars c'est quoi votre vie votre vie
en général mais peut-on mettons là où
fait le podcast ouais ouais c'est quoi
c'est quoi votre passion votre hobby de
bain ou de travail ou au mois de mai
chez mme hussein avait des musiciens
professionnels c'est cool ça tu fus donc
de en fait quand comment vous faites
vous écoutez donc dans plusieurs bennes
août à un band ben j'ai plusieurs balles
j'ai certes un bain avec qui je plus
donc c'est moins
moins fréquents d'autres que c'est
vraiment s'engager pour un contre une
fois tifa que c'est vraiment c'est
rentrer changer
cet été j'ai fait jeter qui tarissent
dans la comédie musicale mamma mia
ok produit par juste pour rire
j'accompagne des artistes je réalise
aussi des artistes
j'ai enregistré jeu sur pichette autour
de projets je fais du corpo aussi j'ai
du cover je fais de la création je dois
faire piquer en fait c'est vraiment son
métier depuis depuis dix ans il t'arrive
a donc à en vivre et et comment tu gères
est-ce que tu as une insécurité à dire
six mois prochain jeu pas de contrat ou
dans trois prochains mois pas de contrat
s'est inscrite rideau sera bon pack halo
ici c'est pas cher peut-être pas la
question si nouveau que je ressens une
insulte et parce que l'homme est en jeu
le gie 28 ans j'approche la trentaine
un jour tu dis j'aimerais peut-être ce
avoir un rythme de vie plus normale plus
stable j'aimerais peut-être
éventuellement avoir des enfants c'est
plus ma part ça ce petit dieu qui est le
site je veux ceci je veux des enfants si
j'avais su ce jeu se inscrire ma vie en
ce moment mais elle permet pc lock it
mais un petit peu plus angoissés ah
ouais parce que moi ça fait des années
que je travaille beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup je brûle contrôle que j'y vais
pas jamais vraiment eu était stressé par
l'argent par l'apport de pas travailler
puis j'ai déménagé à montréal bleu un an
et demi avant j'étais québec perd québec
les joueurs de contre eux en présence
que je faisais il y en avait beaucoup
joué plusieurs plusieurs deux trois
quatre cinq jours par semaine et après
l'autre ça m'a vite j'étais super
heureux là dedans jusqu'à man et je me
dis bon le jeu commence avoir fait le
tour de de ce milieu là de ce style de
contrôle qui était beaucoup de jours
dans des soies des restos bars et puis
jouer des reprises de tubes connus de ce
puits jeu folle appris en faisant ce jeu
devenu vraiment meilleurs musiciens j'ai
appris mon métier
le chéquier de chez vous j'ai besoin
quelque chose de plus je déménage à
montréal
pis leur selleck un peu l'angoissé où
l'espèce de stress est embarquée des
acquis le jeu devrait faire de nouveaux
contacts rencontrer de nouvelles
personnes
j'essaie d'avoir des nouveaux styles de
contrôle qui stimule plus artistiquement
béton puis aussi c'est juste le fait de
vieillir peut se dire cette villa à être
beaucoup sur la route à me coucher très
tard tout le temps et dans les bars tout
le temps c'est le fun à 22h25 à un petit
peu moins 28 à 35 à 45
d'autant que ma tante et moins sur tf1
que le ch d'acheter un gros
questionnement grosse remise en question
existentielle ce qu'est ce que je
ressentais comment je me réoriente pour
avoir une sécurité financière puis être
stimulé artistique le durant ensuite
c'est un passage son cul donc nouveau
dans ma vie que j'ai eu mais en ce
moment je relativement confiant en mes
capacités pialat venez ça a toujours
bien été toujours pas pourquoi ce
journal mais ça se mettrait à l'appui
fonctionner mais il faut que je prenne
le contrôle de ma vie où je m'en vais
plutôt que de me laisser porter
tout laisse à arriver les choses faut
que je ne vois que peu plus les choses
aillent à un débat là-dessus je pense y
ait un débat là-dessus ses intérêts j'ai
lu ton livre d'ailleurs je pense que
tout est plus pour me vois plus le fait
de dénoncer clairement ses objectifs
puis pour tendre vers le web je suis
partagé ah oui tu très partagés
effectivement j'ai écrit ça et je pense
qu'une période de ma vie où je pensais
vraiment ça juste ça et aujourd'hui j'ai
eu cinq ans plus tard je suis partagé
avec yassa et en même temps j'aime
l'idée de laisser les choses venir les
dollars vertus faut juste reconnaître si
les choses deviennent je pense être
assez conscient sur qu'est-ce qu'on les
nippes qu'est-ce qu'on a qu'on dit non
c'est là qu'on dit oui à continent puis
savoir qu'est-ce qu'on veut t en fait
c'est sa voix la reconnaître rapidement
tes c'est savoir ce que tu veux à ce que
les choses qui ça arrive moi justement
cet été
mon contrat que j'ai eu ma meilleure qui
est un con tre d'areva pour un musicien
d'abord autant de dates des 6 bonnes
conditions avec une si belle gagne c'est
ce succès inespéré
et puis moi je veux le dire je pense que
jamais rythme et en même temps d'autres
méritent aussi c'est moi qui lui ai donc
une partie de chance là dedans mais ça
ce n'est pas dans mon plan si je l'avais
pas écrit sur ma liste d'objectifs ça
m'est arrivé comme ceux puisque
n'importe unités incroyable j'ai dit oui
et puis ce justement c'est quelque chose
d'imprévu qui arrive pic d'accueil
abreuvoir mais faut aussi justement
c'est l'oeil avait tout sept autres
parlent de choses que je faisais qui
était que je faisais par habitude je
faisais parce que la route est comme
enclenché puis le lit contrat rentrée se
met à m'amener là roulait dans la
direction direction que je suis pas du
genre à laisser un fait que je peux pas
juste construire laisser rouler par le
il faut que j'essaie de poignées de
valentées puis d'aller dans notre
direction mais c'est ce qui demande un
effort tous ceux qui disent ils qu'ils
mais c'est sûr mais ce qui va faire que
20e en je pense que je vais faire la
place aux jeunes
je pense qu'il veut c'est de savoir ce
que tu veux et quand je parle d'objectif
et après faut pas forcément être
accrochées aux objectifs et on les
laissait vienne où ils viennent pas je
dis moi j'aimerai savoir ça mais pas
être accrochées gros spéciaux et
subjectif c'est à dire que si je
laissais génial si je n'ai pas bah c'est
génial et un a comme ce niveau là c'est
quelque chose de dire tu as ans arrive
ça arrive pas c'est pareil furent pareil
mais reste que tu peux dire j'ai envie
d'aller vers la puis éventuellement ça
tu vois pas prêt à laisser les choses se
faire finalement c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment quétaine et réchauffé de dire
mais c'est vrai que s'élève le chemin et
non l'objectif qu'il ait pas quétaine
non bâti c'est comme ça maintenant
jusqu'à même cet objectif c'est à chaque
jour tu lèves tôt des bonnes habitudes
de vie dit fier de toi tu as compris des
choses dans l'impression de contribuer à
quelque chose tu t'en vas l'elysée le
bonheur tu vois le trou
était bien entouré c'est tout ce que tu
as porté de bonheur la personne bout de
ligne tu finis peau aux olympiques comme
tu avais pensé à être 88 ans s'est amené
sur le chemin était heureusement j'ai
mis dès le matin moi de me lever d'avoir
une discipline 3 way the kid mais bien à
ta journée puis chacun sa discipline qui
est simple que tout le monde peut faire
que je trouve c'est la respiration tu
respires pendant 3 minutes et les
aspirations profondes petit mais durant
fait encore d'oxygène et après tu dis
juste tu prends un deux trois mêmes pour
deux postures merci pour les choses pour
lesquelles que quotas dans ta vie tu
vois une espèce de truc de barrett est
ce qu'on fout de ma gueule par rapport à
ça d'un côté le côté gratitude de dire
on a tous la chance d'avoir beaucoup de
choses dans ma vie
ouais on veut beaucoup de choses mais on
assure on a aussi beaucoup de choses
quand tu regardes est juste dire merci
pour tout ce que tu as réalisé que tu es
chanceux te met dans un espèce d'état
comme ça aide beaucoup je pense que tu
vois et c'est juste une route des
routines absolument simple qui change en
tout cas pour moi ma journée est donc ma
semaine et tu de la bière sans titre
gabon va depuis 30 ans il m'écoute
moyennement en forme j'aime l'idée de la
routine cgem vidéo mais moi je comme ça
parce que on dirait que ça me fais pas
ça me ça me met dans la journée ça me
tue
l'énergie dégagée l'énergie que tu vas
recevoir aussi et puis moi je sais j'ai
j'essaie de le faire je suis vraiment
pas bon quand j'ai perfectionné l'art de
d'être positif en me levant mettons mais
j'ai l'impression que j'aurais beaucoup
à gagner à être capable de faire seul à
prendre le temps de me lhbib hajji va
pas essayer de faire ça commençait à le
feu commence à faire ce genre de choses
de me lever pour dire à qui aujourd'hui
je suis chanceux de ce que j'ai je
remercie d'anticiper sur sa fille qu tu
es déjà plus réceptif à l'énergie
positive j'ai l'impression stand dégage
toi moi je pense que j'ai un ami qui dit
ça il
phrase i on on attire ce qu on vibre
ouais tu vois on attire ce qu'on veut
dire ce qu on vibre et je trouve ça beau
comme tu as marqué les gens à tirer
juste de la mare dans leur vie we love
is to say continuellement de la marde
étant assez continuellement beau et tu
te dis qu'est ce qui se passe entre ces
deux jours là parce qu'ils sont nés au
même endroit ils ont de même âge ils ont
plus ou moins les mêmes chances ils ont
du talent les deux mais pourquoi ils
n'ont qu'à toi de la marde et le casino
juste des belles choses et tu dis
derrière quelque chose d'autre que j'ai
juste de la chance
abandonnés et j'ai l'impression mais ça
c'est ça c'est des croyances après c'est
moi j'ai pas du tout religieux mais je
crois qu'il ya des choses qu'on voit qui
t'aident je crois que les choses ont
traîné dans un espèce d'état où tu peux
t'aider et attirer les choses plus belle
je crois à ça moi je crois ça fait mal
disney là mais je crois à la magie de la
vie alors j'étais je mangeais à saint
lambert chef dans un restaurant venir
vous voir les gars et auquel j'étais
jamais allé je trouve un restaurant
végétarien
si jamais elle est dedans tout les
restaurants il doit y avoir 17 place
dedans et je m'assois et cc des tabous
assis les uns à côté des autres est
vraiment est serrée en fait donc en fait
pas tant vraiment à discussion des gens
à côté
et donc je m'assois je commence à manger
et y avait de madame qui était assise à
une autre table finalement les sites de
vient s'asseoir à côté parce que savoir
plus confortable et elle se met l'appui
en revenait je pas pourquoi je le mets
regarder les gens parce que des fois je
fais ça j'aime bien m'essayer me
connecter aux gens et voir comment ils
se sentent c'est un jeu que j'ai agi
comme ça et je regarde la madame est
pris à la droite comme ça juste un petit
regard est la marraine la fée ou excusez
nous on se parlait comme on se parle on
est on est serré donc est désolé madame
je vous écoute est pas juste eu envie de
vous regarder une seconde mais je vous
écoute et pas et elle commence à me
parler là madame et dirai pas son nombre
on va l'appeler sophie et commence à me
parler de sa vie et elle me dit qu'elle
a rencontré à l'adapter 59 ans elle a
rencontré à présentant un monsieur de 45
ans et elle se dit pourquoi il est avec
moi pourquoi il même le sujet rien
d'attirant pour lui beaucoup plus
vieille que lui mais il veut connaître
dans le sud pendant une deux semaines
foutu cherchant ma part aux chambres
séparées et là vraiment un vrai dilemme
de madame car un dilemme dans sa vie et
moi je dis madame le mieux qu'on puisse
faire c'est parler avec ton coeur bat
voir ce monsieur l'a dit lui commence
800 enlève ce masque cela soit vrai état
et on a parlé je feuillette en retard
ici en fait je vais partir et on a parlé
une demi heure avec madame la savane
arriver là
tavin j'arrive et je dis et je me dis
ouais mais souvent dans la vie moi je
savais qu'un homme puisse chat qui va me
laisser chèque
tu vas tu vois pourquoi tu penses qu'il
laisse les hommes étaient
continuellement en train de dire que
toute façon tu vas te faire de laisser
ces questions pense qu'il va arriver
dans ta vie c'est ça qui se passe en
fait ta vie elle est géniale tu as
rencontré un homme qui a 45 ans qui est
jeune qui tique a envie de toi profite
sans ta vie est magique
regardons ensemble on est en train de se
parler je suis à côté de toi dans le
restaurant je viens de dire de réaliser
à quel point on se connaît pas jamais
venu ici je suis assis acheter 10 la
diva c'est vrai réalise moi je pense que
la vie est magique tu vois j'ai cette
vision là échec ça va très mal 10 ne
suis très conscient de ça mais je pense
que la vie est magique mais qui ont
souvent la voit pas mais tu fais des
rencontres tu dis comment ça j'ai
rencontré ce gala à tel endroit
ça va amener à telle chose le hasard
mois le hasard on dirait que j'ai pas
envie d'y croire
on dirait que moi j'ai une vision de ces
la satire et ça ça marche peu après ça
va t'elle shopi cette vision là que la
vie peut être peut être magique
je sais que ça peut être très drôle pour
beaucoup de gens mais ça n'est pas juste
c'est quoi le nom tu mets ce que le mot
qui met dessus c'est moi j'appelle
possède la magie mais c'est sûr que
d'être positif d'être d'exprimer la
gratitude des gentilles qu'ils ont
d'autres autour de toi c'est le départ
de revenir
est ce que c'est de la magie ou est-ce
que ces gosses mais qu'est ce que c'est
les ondes ou c'est juste site entretient
les relations des bonnes relations que
j'entre de toi c'est éventuellement
salvatrice positif - oui je crois pas à
la magie en guillemets mais je crois en
ce principe le de ces deux bonnes
personnes aux meilleures personnes
possibles d'abord des bonnes vibes
métaux de base dans ce sens pendant 107
terrible du terme d'audience bonne
personne
ouais ça monsieur pays hôte eric tu
rencontre quelqu'un puis tu vois qu'il
ya énergie de marque n'a pas le goût de
parler avec 120 quelqu un filet ouvert
il est souriant il intéressé à toi taku
parle avec tout à fait et pourtant c'est
quoi ils vont rencontrer entre ces deux
jours là bas c'est juste l'énergie qu'il
a ses génériques qui met à être souriant
soit faire la gueule tu vois il le dit
d'ailleurs dans les entretiens les tu
prends deux personnes même âge même
gueule même expérience même et ses
séquelles qui va avoir le travail
c'est ce qui en joue et celui qui a
envie et un français qui disait moi je
préfère engager un jeune pas d'étude
mais avec eux qui en joue et qu'un
un qu'un gars qu'un diplôme d'art varde
mais qui fait la gueule
moi je veux le gars ont joué ça est
beaucoup plus agréable savait beaucoup
plus productif de travers et la toux
grasse tu peux la prendre et je pense
que ça joue beaucoup de latitude que tu
as tu vois et c'est ça quand je dis la
magie sept matchs tu dois avoir un
impact sur les gens qui fait que ça va
être plus agréable d'être plus attirés
par toi c'était ouvert j'étais
complètement fermée grincheux et tu fais
la gueule tu vois exactement puis tôt ou
tard c'est cette gentillesse le cette
banque et il va finir par te revenir
parce que les gens veulent plus enclins
à aider les terrans service est forte et
puis faut un pôle phare dans cette
optique là mais c'est ce qui va arriver
moi je pense moi moi moi j'aime voir la
magie partout une belle vision de la vie
dans les jeux la discothèque avec l'idée
fataliste de dire quelque chose de plus
grand qui gèrent nos âmes aussi qui
jarno notre chemin au sens où de dirhams
et on est quelque chose de négatif qui
m'arrive mais c'est parce qu'il ya plus
grands il ya un plan plus grands qui
m'est destinée tuer ceux qui croient pas
mais de dire que y'a rien qui arrive
pour rien puis de deux sites en voit
quelque chose puis si tu arrive quelque
chose ça t'arrive pour pour que ta prime
sur toi même
puis quand justement monsieur je veux
parler pour moi parce que c'est mon
expérience en ce moment il ya des
situations qui arrive à ce que je me dis
qu'ils disent si j'étais capable d'avoir
d'être plus positif de jeu c'est être
plus accueillant des énergies des autres
mettront probablement que j'aurai je
regarde dallas d'atteindre un haut
niveau dans mon cheminement personnel
puis pitié je pense que le dis ce que tu
dis là ça résonne beaucoup parce que
parce que je pense que je l'engrais
grandement force et c'est le moins et
c'est lui une semaine de me lever le
matin et
une semaine et essaient de champ est
situé à paris c'est juste pour le fun ok
en fait c'est l'expérience et où il eut
la côte et commence à me saouler avec
mes et salue une semaine et c'est de
changer ton négatif par du positif juste
pour essayer c'est sûr que ça va c'est
sûr ça va ça va changer beaucoup
d'apprendre ça c'est absolument certain
que tu peux de centres et de positif
mais voilà la formulation à rien car
ivoirien a à me dérange ok pourquoi
parce qu'il y ait des choses n'arrive
pour rien dans la vie c'est comme se
mordent la langue devant une pizza
manger une pizza pochette devant
occupation de ce qu'elles considèrent
pas vraiment ces choses là quand ça
c'est un des plus grands maux de notre
société moderne
non mais tu es un petit gain de 10 ans
qui en a lui aussi mis ça arrive pour
rien si y'a pas tirer s'il ya pas voulu
souiller pas choisi ce ça arrive pendant
non mais maintenant quand tu le prends 2
du point de vue du parent par exemple ou
est ce que il perd son son petit garçon
oui puisque c'est la plus grande épreuve
de tout temps mais pour toi faut que tu
fasses que c'est pas arrivé pour rien je
comprends qu'il transcrit 6 à 6 pour toi
pour le reste de ta vie c'est arrivé
pour rien c'est juste la plus la plus
grosse cicatrice qui qui va jamais guéri
je ne le comprends puisque comprendre ce
que tu arrives une fatalité comme
somnifère horrible de quand même
apprécié le choix de laisser mourir de
leur tourner ou d'essayer de vent qui se
met la vie quand même injuste souvent
pour que le gars est souvent tout à fait
la vie il faut finir juste un acquis qui
en a qui danse dans tout leur est donnée
foule privilèges sur tous les aspects y
en a qui conquit qui viennent des vies
misérables ses pôles de leur forte mais
messi je comprends aussi quelque chose
que tu arrives to toujours une option de
commenter de l'élection mais les choses
qui arrivent qui se sait juste injuste
puisque c'est pô si c'est paulette le
pot à tirer ma part je suis d'accord en
énergie n'est pas choisie kg a rien qui
arrive pour rien je peux rien qui
t'arrive
parce que tu te dis je
il ya des impacts arrive que c'est pas
toi qui as amené mais rien n'arrive pour
rien au sens où quand watsa t envoyer
faut que tu en fasses quelque chose de
pas le choix tu vois moi je suis quelque
chose comme ça qui arrive c'est dur
c'est horrible c'est dégueulasse est
triste c'est injuste ouamane toi même tu
as perdu ton passage ils ont permis rien
quand j'ai vu tant et à ce moment là il
ya ça arrive pour rien dessus et je
pense qu'il ya un an
ce qu'on sait pas tout si on sait pas ce
qu'il ya on s'est passé on t on alors on
parle d'énergie subtil on parle de dieu
on parle de personnes c'est est ce qu'il
ya un après escapade après ce qui est
juste une vie où ça s'arrête
même en personne la réponse ça se peut
qu'un jour tu meurs effet karine il ya
un après et que c'était que rangs
l'après et quand je faisais mon sens
fait trois ce cas maintenant j'essaie de
la marque
c'est don mateo je suis ça se peut non
je dis il ya une possibilité si tu te
faire maintenant c'est celle là c'est
fini mais imaginent demain tu meurs et
je ferai pas non dans 80 ans tu meurs et
se retrouve au paradis eh bien il ya
quelque chose parce que c'est joli ça se
comprend on sait pas mais même les faits
de vivre avait acquis rien je vois pas
ce comme ben revivre une vie ni les
aspects de la vie absurde vérité épi yo
rien après puis la vie et l'aide
même si juste une vie à vivre ça veut
pas dit et puis quand même vivre une vie
de bonté et de générosité de vouloir
faire une différence pour pour les gens
après toi même studio après ce mot je
voyais scrupuleux votre corps en
décomposition puis mon corps va se faire
manger par les re c'est quand même
possible de vouloir le mieux pour les
générations futures et pour les gens
autour de toi
owen en fait le point il voulait amener
c'est quand il arrive un événement
horrible comme ça qui effectivement est
horrible
j'ai perdu mon père fait que ces
horribles voir ton père - quant à 8 ans
c'est une des pires choses qui puissent
arriver je pense est et reste que reste
que ces événements là nous apporter
plein de choses dans ma famille on dit
beaucoup plus solidaire moi ça m'a fait
souffrir mais autant que ça m'a apporté
plein plein plein d'autres choses tu
vois c'est importé plein de choses je
pense que une partie de mon métier je
dois au fait que j'ai mon père mourir
le fait que maintenant je sois axé
beaucoup sur ma santé parce que je vois
mon père mourir gilles mon père fut mais
je voyais mon père boire et que j'ai pas
fumer j'ai pas bu tu vois il ya beaucoup
de choses finalement qui ont découlé de
ça qu'ils m'ont qui m'ont aidé tac
effectivement la mort de mon père après
la mort de mon père peut-être qu'il ya
quelque chose de 2,2 je sais pas je ne
sais pas peut-être que peut-être que
peut-être que ça allait se passer comme
ça peut-être que je sais pas ça ça c'est
dit je m'étais peut-être parce que j'ai
pas envie de dire bah non c'est pas
comme ça finalement un jour je vais à la
crise j'ai été con parce que finalement
c'est ça tu as fait que je vais je dis
je laissais un espèce de d'ouverture à
ça se peut ce jeu pas être c'est comme
je viens de matter ya présentement son
et flics ils pensent que la terre est
plate
ils veulent te prouver que la terre est
plate mais et puis là on l'a prouvé que
scientifiquement c'est pas vrai la terre
est ronde il ya des choses comme ça
qu'on connaît pas et on aurait l'air
content c'est à dire finalement il ya
quelque chose d'autre et que je veux
rester ouverts à ça ce quelque chose de
plus grand et peut-être qu'un enfant cas
une leucémie
nous on trouve ça horrible et c'est
horrible mais peut-être qu'à un niveau
plus grand mais quelque chose de beau là
dedans et je ne sais pas tu vois je vois
que je reste est ouvert à ça tu
comprends ce que je viens je passe juste
me limiter à je comprends la souffrance
elle est là la justice la souffrance est
horrible mais mais je comprends à la
pâte un sourire doivent alors j'ai
limité entre individus on perd c'est
juste que je veux rester ouverts surface
qui était quelque chose d'autre que
juste nous ici maintenant parce que je
suis exactement
bon je vais conserver l'ouverture par
rapport à ceux oui mais je relève mme
zahra penser que que tout ce qui se
passe pour les tueries mettons dans une
école aux passants c'est horrible
qu'est-ce que peu importe là peu importe
la raison
admettons faisons l'hypothèse que que
finalement tout les les gens qui les
gens qui décèdent dans des tragédies
comme ce fût ce à partir de ce moment là
ça commence à être la vraie affaire
coule-t-il tombe dans la presse que la
presse est débile mais j'ai de la misère
à avoir su que la misère à accepter en
fait
que si avec quelque chose de plus grand
j'ai vraiment de la misère à accepter
tout ce qui se passe en syrie c'est
horrible c'est ça on peut pas enlever
leur éviter de se cacher quelque chose
de plus grâce et de lessines marre de
cette affaire là parce que parce que ça
fait souffrir vraiment un sachet
d'accord avec toi peut pas enlever
l'horreur de ce conte un enfant qui
meurt d'une leucémie ou ta fille qui
sait tirer dessus
c'est horrible on peut pas enlever ça ça
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec toi et
après je suis pas en train de dire qu'il
ya quelque chose je voudrais je veux
rester ouvert à la possibilité que
quelque chose d'autre dit pas que c'est
ça parce que je le sais pas ça doit tête
mais j'ai jamais perdu quelqu'un proche
de moi doigt sur le vécu définitivement
mais c'est l'incompréhension puis c'est
souvent ce qui s'est souvent face à
l'incompréhension qu'on essaie de
s'expliquer qui connaissait s'expliquer
en disant c'est sûrement je peux pas
croire que c'est ce je peux pas croire
que c'est gratuit demain comme seul jeu
par mon père donc je peux pas croire je
peux pas je peux pas concevoir que y'a
rien qui justifie ce qui vient d'arriver
assez horrible ça pour l'art avec juste
horrible et moi j'ai 8 ans et à 8 ans je
me rendais pas compte de ce que huit ans
le concept de la mort c'est dans un
extrait je me suis rendu compte que plus
tard monteux rendu compte que que plus
tard et wes et je vois sa personne comme
est ce que tu sais comment est-ce que la
partie de leur sens justement tombé dans
croire qu'il est parti pour quelque part
mon erreur ou peut-être que c'est ça que
tu que tu penses hook était ouvert à
l'idée mais comment est-ce que tu tu
réagis avec cette incrédulité avec 7,7
avec cette incompréhension le quota huit
ans tu comprends pas donc tu comprends
pas et en grandissant je pense je
reconnais que c'est avec ça il ya
quelques années mais à thury en fait il
rien faire tu fais juste souffrir et tu
pleures était triste et un traumatisme
tu vis avec ça je pense je sais pas de
comprendre pourquoi c'est arrivé où j'ai
juste de voir que cela m'a apporté et de
deux des six parce que c'est ça ouais de
de guérir sa jusque j'aime l'idée de
dire c'est pas parce que c'est pas
prouvé que ça n'existe pas tu vois
j'aime bien cette théorie la personne
s'il ya un an après on sait pas s'il ya
quelque chose après la mort du pape
l'a prouvé mais que ça veut dire que
parce qu'on n'a pas prouvé que ça
n'existe pas tu vois j'ai pas envie de
me limiter à ça parce que j'ai besoin
d'avoir l'air con et d'arrivée après
accra en fait on s'est tous trompés il y
avait que je dois je rester vraiment
ouvert et en fait je me suis rendu
compte que les gens qui ont vécu des
choses horribles
la plupart des gens qui ont vécu des
choses horribles on parle de leucémie on
parle de mort d'un proche comparé à ces
gens là en plus deux de profondeur et de
lumière en eux je trouve que ce compact
besoin de spiritualité souvent parce que
si j'imagine que c'est un réflexe
naturel aussi devant l'horreur dans des
choses dicibles devant des questions
auxquelles on n'a pas de réponse à
essayer d'en trouver puis essaie d'en
chercher c'est pisser pour ce mois je
pense que c'est pour ça que m'est témoin
je pars avec le présupposé que met-on
l'homme écrit les religions on t'aime et
on les écrit en réponse à justement
qu'on soit la non connaissance ou soit
justement la douleur de perdre des
proches bâti j'ai perdu j'ai perdu un
proche au moins et mieux maintenant ça
fait du bien
ou justement c'est quoi ce lézard tout
ce que je peux pas concevoir peut pas
compris comprendre ce bain je les
remplis avec quelque chose s'est dit
quelque chose qui qui qui peut être
super bo qui peut aider à mieux à mieux
vivre pendant certaines questions à
penser certaines bien sûr mais ça reste
une création je pense souvent les
croyances pendant ce temps là pour nous
faire pour nous rassurer sachez d'accord
avec toi
reste que t'as vu c'est passé remarqué
il ya beaucoup de documentaires sur les
les
zammit ce qu'on fait des morts éminente
way et qui décrypte ce qu'ils vont être
qu'ils ont vécu il ya un livre là-dessus
qui s'appelle la promesse du paradis
c'est un grand médecin un grand
neurochirurgien qui disait après cette
vie là tout s'arrête je vous le dis a
passé sa vie à dire ça à dire tout
s'arrête arrêtez de délirer quand les
gens vont de la lumière c'est votre
cerveau qui fait ça vous délirez le nerf
optique six as et ça bon moi je suis
scientifique soit autant que je peux
arrêter vos conneries à rien après et un
jour ce gala tombe dans le coma et via
un truc hallucinant pendant une semaine
les médecins il se fonde les branchies
va mourir ou syrien il va être légumes
toute sa vie finalement il revient et il
en santé il raconte tout ce qu'il a vécu
et maintenant il passe sa vie à faire a
dit alain verdeaux ce qu'il faisait
pendant 20 ans un médecin c'est un
neurochirurgien
j'y racontais pendant 20 ans qui avait
rien eh ben j'ai vu quelque chose
d'autre et maintenant je vous racontais
que tu vois ça mais ça pose des
questions ça mène à pretoria sion il ya
beaucoup énormément d'histoires qui vont
dans ce sens-là de mort imminente
définitivement intéressant après ce
rejet mais non plus si c'est une
fabulation du cerveau qui est quelque
chose de quelqu'un qui veut la mort
piqué que ou si c'est réellement quelque
chose de plus tu sais
d'un côté ou de l'autre s'ils s'imposent
ce pays possède a approuvé à savoir tire
donc c'est le départ ça reste en bout de
ligne une question de croyance tripy
ouais ça reste une question croyances
ça reste un mystère il ya quelque chose
de quelque chose de troublant imaginer
le jeu par complètement mais je trouve
quelque chose de troublant imaginer que
tout ce qu'on vit les interactions qu'on
en ce moment que l'addiction qui nous
fait réfléchir en ce moment que tout ça
est juste éphémère c'est le jeu fait je
fais vraiment de la philo des cégeps et
je trouve je trouve ça troublant de
penser que c'est une possibilité que
tout ce que tout ça demain matin peut
avoir servi à rien en face à szavay rien
mettre six mois demain matin je me fais
frapper par un chant ça vous savez rien
non mais ça va pas ça ne va rien pour le
joueur je vais parler complètement
centré sur moi même
ça a peut être servi à quelque chose
pour le monde qui nous écoutent ça va
peut être servir à quelque chose pour
vous deux sets pour nicole même certains
mais j'ai de la misère à penser que pour
mon pour ma conscience pour moi pour mon
corps pour moi je la misère à penser que
ce ça va avoir terminé c'est comme ça me
fait ça me rend un peu étourdi de penser
que peut-être que demain matin cela ne
ferait pas encore dati c'est vrai n'ont
même pas pensé à ça une seconde de dire
que tout ce qu'on passe notre vie à
faire à une date indéfinie
je suis d'accord que puisque tu disais
tantôt c'est tout à fait vrai dire je
veux que les gens après moi je vais
avoir un impact positif sur le monde
dans lequel je vis maintenant mais d'un
point de vue ultra égocentrique de dire
ça se pourrait que demain matin
tout ce ça finisse c'est pour ça que la
théorie la théorie l'hypothèse
l'hypothèse des hommes qui obligent leur
vie passée mais qui garde un bagage
émotif ou émotionnel un peu un peu le
bouddhisme tient un peu à la l'idée de
la réincarnation puis de passer d'une
vie à une autre moi je suis pas 100 %
réticences comme une théorie à laquelle
j'adhère plus que il
paradis puis l'enfer puis l'après vie
religieuse catholicisme on dirait que ça
raisonne plus en moi parce que j'ai
vraiment de la difficulté à imaginer que
sinon même antenne le frapper dati
depuis mon nom ma plomb soit en se
termine ici et ici ça calme d'angoissé
existentielle que tout est à dire ce fan
ouais ça n'a fait pas que c'est plus et
après ça on est libre de dettes à des
croyances qu'on veut c'est celle nous
fondement et finalement est ce qu on
partait de son positivisme étant
négative et c'est juste pour le fun
ouais fait l'expérience générale est
justement une vidéo youtube il ya
quelques jours ils paraissent a
justement du pouvoir d'arriver à
rechange et ton négatif en posant moins
de ce match et que sa sueur sur internet
mais c'est intéressant et c'est juste
pour le fun et puis je te parle je parle
que quand tu as une situation négative
baissé de 2,2 peut le voir positif et de
m juste pour ça veut dire ne pas être
triste ne pas être en colère ne pas être
stressé parce que j j'essaie de
reformuler de façon positive
juste pour voir si ton cerveau à avoir
une situation qui la verrait des
prémices négative
l'examen positif de mein fauqué tonton
conditionnement et ait pas ce que veut
pas notre conditionnement qu'on a on l'a
pris de la on l'a pris des informations
de nos parents de professeurs de nos
amis tu vois et on est conditionné à est
d'une certaine façon mais est donc ce
conditionnement amène certains résultats
dans notre vie peu importe lequel
mais si tu veux changer les résultats
faux tu changes ce que ce que tu fais ça
je me dis est ce qu'il ya des façons et
ça et c'est le fait l'expérience et
alors on disait essaye le thème génial
c'est un passe temps je vois pas
pourquoi je vais essayer de voir ce que
ça amène comme résultat pour moi c'est
pas la première fois qu'on ait cette
discussion c'est très net de seppi dans
ton livre tu parles du film yes man brad
pitt houssin je sais que ça fume pas
parler ouais je sais qu'il parle parce
que les remarques parce que tidjane
gadio début du film toi tu es way moins
maintenant mais oui mais
ce qui est drôle c'est que c'est les
mêmes questionnements qui reviennent
alors que toi non toi je sens que les
plus réfractaires à votre choix
réfractaire à bas un bon sceptiques foie
gras-cèpes si tout ça puis je pense
qu'il n'est ni d extraordinaire
évidemment anglais est horrible mais
comment ce que je dis pas ce que je vais
pas d'équivalent en france amateur il
ferait preuve exactement ces sites avant
ce quelque chose d'extraordinaire foot+
l'eba qui avec des preuves extra c'est
ce que je pense puis après seul tout le
monde est libre georges n'a jamais
empêché qui que ce soit de croire qui
que ce soit celle du fils bien l'eau par
exemple où j'ai une limite c'est caen
qui salue une influence ou ou que ça
affecte d'autres gens autour d'eux
autour négativement ces quatre impose
certaines croyances à d'autres ou sa
déraison léger problème explique mais
moi je suis juste un ingrat sceptique
mais je suis pas complètement fermé puis
le cycle à la science pour réponse à
tous en ce moment il ya de la fois qu'on
n'a pas encore découvert la fac on sait
pas encore ça fait qu'on va se rendre
compte dans dix quinze vingt ans 50 ans
et en études en chant et tel traitement
qu'on donnait et boy on ne l'avait pas
pantoute
mais je pense quand même qu'il faut
évidemment qu'il faut se fier à son
instinct son good feeling dans la vie
surtout sur des choses qui sont
subjectives ou solides et des fois dans
la vie est arrivé un dilemme
tu as peut-être quelque chose mais
termine instinct qui dit autre chose
je pense que dans certaines situations
faut quand même l'écouter cette petite
voix le ce genre de good feeling là
parce qu'il est souvent raison mais dans
des certain que ou le gotta feeling ou
l'instinct et nuls c'est combien de fois
combien de fois on entend maintenant une
journée qui fait vraiment froid fret au
québec lui fait moins 40 prête atention
couples qui ont écrit sur facebook puis
après ça ils vont nous faire accroire
que je reçois qui m'a serré
je pense que tu as froid aujourd'hui que
le réchauffement climatique est pas un
phénomène réel temps parce qu'ils
étaient censés te dit quelque chose
c'est télé matin que le matin connaît
l'énergie à 5h30 du matin un piquet il
faisait méritera ma vie c'est pire
moment on allait à la piscine à 5h30 le
matin et rentrer un déclic et puis tiens
qui fait moins 32 arbitres juges elle
petit titre brillamment à ste relève
toujours du tout en fait de froid peu
froid pénétrant le titre réveilles tu es
déjà froid le tu t'habilles sort dehors
du mont dans l'auto titre en piscine qui
conduit l'étude en piscine puis apparaît
bouillante paraît show d'abc davout ce
matin puis un versement qui fait qu'à 35
d'europe taux d'aps insar même
température des piscines à la fois king
frites nos sens nous trompera une
température mais ont des perceptions
différentes dans des coûts de la science
exactement c'est pas parce que dans un
certain feeling certains instincts que
''c'était bien guidé les choses en
sciences qui sont tellement
contre-intuitive pics sont vraies qui
s'apparenterait à la magie mais qui es
tu et la physique quantique
je connais rien je connais pas ni
intérêt ce métier personne comprend
grand chose
l'adap armand avoir fait un docteur
c'est excessivement contre intuitif
ça nous apparaît comme absolument
farfelue mais les technologiques sont
basés là dessus on prédit des événements
qui vont qui vont sport qui qui vont se
passer avec une exactitude ahurissante
on en ont prédit mathématiquement
certain particules que avec des
technologies d'accélérateur de
particules de protons fait rentrer deux
protons un an l'autre invité à lumière
puis on la voit la molécule pour les
capable de de la mesure et puis des
savoirs sa masse qui ça concorde avec
les mathématiques qu'on avait de ce on
fait roi au nautisme et des choses qui
existent sont réels qui sont pour qu'on
découvre qu'on invente pas qu'on
découvre qu'ils existent
sur passe complètement notre entendement
d'être un saint je comprends je
comprends je comprends côté je comprends
très cartésien près rationnelle très
scientifique très pour le croire pour
autant pour tâche un artiste je suis
artiste puis chez quelqu'un quand même
proche de ses émotions je lis qu'un
cador la cada aux nouveaux cas dans la
musique adresse mes mains mais je
capable de compartimenter deux fois
certaines sociétés l'ordre du subjectif
des émotions puisque c'est dans la
sphère de l'objectif qui j'essaie de les
séparer
parce que dans la spa de l'objectif ton
émotions ou la croyance lie la gravité
la science de la force de gravité existe
que tu y croit ou non pas beaucoup y
croire avoir existé quand même dieu ou
peu importe n'est pas quelle croyance
plus subjective belle si c'est toi qui
est qui qui qui décide de la mer
n'existe qui décide des tirs alors
l'article 17 de peine à faire mais c'est
pas toi qui décide si la force de
gravité un effet sur toi ou non est ce
que tu aimes bono musiciens et pas en
terme de musique
bah j'ai rien qu'en bonne trouve que
c'est un grand artiste est ce que je
trouve que ce que tu as dit il et a du
respect pour ce qu'il a fait je déroge
de respect pour youtube pour ce club
parce que lui bono il dit que la façon
dont il écrit ses chansons c'est que lui
c'est juste une antenne ouais tu vois
lui donc là ça rentre ça ça sera contre
tout ce que tu en train de dire aux
[ __ ] à la baie c'est quoi une antenne
la chanson existe déjà et son travail à
lui si je de la capter la version papier
je ne suis pas complètement fermé ses
six défaites fpi pour toi pourquoi la
musique le team et on la musique
occidentale du moins est basée sur la
gamme majeur de dorignies face à l'acide
au 6 juin douze pianos si je joue un peu
près pas d'instrument la note de la note
principale à fréquence principal savait
que la fréquence qui crée le dos au
milieu d'autres fréquences qui résonne
grappes et les harmoniques la première
harmonie qu'on veut entendre
c'est un seul une canette qu'on appelle
c'est la fréquence qui est libre le plus
le plus harmonieusement avec cette
fréquence le lautrec ans qui résonne
quand tu joues seulement une note mais
que qu'on peut percevoir dans cette note
le 6 1 me qui la troisième fréquence qui
fait vivre le le plus en concordance
avec ce que ça donne un accord majeur
puis après ça c'est comme on a tout bâti
de la musique là dessus mais ceci c'est
très physique
donc c'est comme si la corde d'eau ces
scanneurs est notre avis ne sonne le
mieux ce qui nous sommes les plus
concordants le plus beau mais met même à
un enfant ou même est probablement à un
animal c'est un accord de d'autres aussi
mais ton dos et soeurs au juste un doux
mais après ce il ya des fréquences qui
vibre très très très mal
l'une avec l'autre mais ton dos fa dièse
les saguenéens sont vraiment pas beau
j'ai joué un double fadial safa a requis
ce mal est je prends moi que je jouerai
101 chine ferait a requis ce mal est
fait expérience mais je peux pas les
chiens fonctionner mais bref c'est comme
si tous les fondements de la musique
était déjà inscrit dans la nature dans
les vibrations
comment ce que je dis comme si la gamme
de dos l'accord de doha le pas inventé
on est juste découvert ok c'est ça c'est
ça avec la science cc c'est intéressant
de penser que de devoir de ne pas
inventer des accords mais de les
découvrir
ben parce que ces possibilités d accord
c b filtration et des notes libération
des fréquences donc les possibilités
existent déjà
après ce cdd et sailly lez bono qui
retire les chansons bâti après ce soit
des chansons j'avais j'avais un prof au
à l'université moi j'ai fait mon ma
maîtrise en littérature
j'avais un prof qui nous avait fait un
exercice lüssy comme ceux qui écrivaient
ces livres c'est romain puisaye
il comparaît son métier d'écrivain à un
métier d'archéologue they l'histoire
existe
l'histoire est là l'histoire existe dans
un cosmos dans l'univers les fake
tout ce que j'ai besoin de faire comme
écrivain c'est de la découvrir
fake fait l'exercice mettons hautement
puis j'invite tous ceux qui nous
écoutent en ce moment à faire une chose
imaginez une sangle fait que tu as un
monsieur avec un chapeau melon dans un
café à partir de justes cette image là
tu es capable de découvrir l'histoire de
ce monsieur le haut de ce café lounge
ans dans cette scène si tu peux partir à
l'infini et lui donner l'exemple
d'amener mon écrivait puis son
personnage principal il rentre en train
mais ils ont remarqué en écrivain que
son personnage boîte et puis ça il
l'écrivait pilleurs marquer ça en
écrivant le terran du think small plein
dit qu'à mon personnage s'est assis dans
le train à la hauteur de ses pantalons
quinquis et a6 et pantalons relevés
puis il y avait une jambe de bois mais
qui a été découvert calais mais au début
quand son personnage bout était dans le
train ils savaient même pas ce qu'ils
découvrent le film dekowski écrite
génial j'adore ça mais imagine si même
chose pour un numéro d'humour
l'imaginent citons la blague elle existe
mais la blague alizés ce qui est ou
ouais trouvons là ouais mais j'aime bien
ça moi je pense comme ça j'avais entendu
jason mraz que j'aime et où ce que
j'aime beaucoup comme moi comme chanteur
ouais et puis bono ami samuel ce qu'il
disait ça et moi ça me parle beaucoup
pensent que la création existe et qu'on
a juste à la capter et c'est comme ça
que je parle de magie de la vie donc
j'aime bien voir parce que apparemment
vous êtes deux complètement peut-être et
rationnelle des traits yes man moi je ne
bouge pas innocent mallet semaine les
jeux de plus en plus
ouvert à plus que le quartier du moins
j'essaie de la fin ce film-là ya ce
match sera un bon exemple est tout à
fait y est complètement fermé non pas
non non pas le patois le personnage
vraiment fermé à la vie y'a rien qui
aille avec un coût inférieur il paie qui
le rend si la france est malade il est
trop bon s'il m'a vraiment drôle et d'un
coup il rentre dans ce cas là il dit oui
à tout et ça lui devient génial mais ça
serait marrant c'est qu'on fasse
l'expérience terre battue de films
j'aime faire ça pour vrai mais c'est sûr
quand même joué allardyce man chaque fin
de soirée amène à quelque chose de sexy
tu veux juste dire oui à tout ça se peut
des fois tu te ramasses dans un geste ou
à vivre une soirée nahd qui auront rien
positif je pense pas que ces bons
conseils adonix même la morale du film
ce krach est la conclusion du film c'est
pas nécessairement qu'il faut dire oui à
tout non c'est sûr c'est que le guide il
a déjà scellé le gourou lui fais ramené
il voit qui fête jeudi oui tous des
bains maures et sa décapotable le
message et bon séjour de conseils je
pense qui peut être super bon et valide
pour certaines personnes
vingt personnes qui sont complètement
fermés justement qui qui souffre pas
d'une expérience kiki puis il ya des
gens qui disent trop hui des fois aussi
des gens qui veulent plaire à tout le
monde des gens qui disent oui à tous et
qui s'écoute pas le même trip il faut
trouver juste je pense le juste
équilibre entre ces deux choses lampe
pour dire oui à tout pour dire non à
tout payer des gens qui disent trop nom
des gens qui disent trop oui faut foot
juste trouver la bonne classe là dedans
c'est tu dis oui à tout et décide de
construire quelque chose c'est tout
parler de routine chaque matin les
valeurs de fait en routine à nana na na
na hey tu dis oui à tout le petit peut
pas avoir cette routine là parce que
nous routine demande que tu dises nom
des enfants parce que sinon tu peux
repos
si six tableaux de dix ans resterait
donc dormir coller deux ans de plus avec
moi je dis oui à ce le tas drenthe est
en train d
et ce capital routine si tu dis oui au
fait d emprunter un autre baron précieux
un autre shooter petite couche à 90
matin un bain chaud trop beau talent
vers 600 photos méditation c'est donc je
pense faut apprendre à savoir qu'est ce
qu'on veut savoir c'est votre
personnalité savoir dire non d'y
renoncer après tout si une vertu à
sarrouilles quand j'ai dit oui à tous et
pas toute ta vie
moi c'est fait l'expérience une semaine
au haut débit à tous une semaine comme
quoi tout à l'heure appréciée après un
débat justifie ce plan social
tu te sens tu dises d'iweb juste pour
voir ce qui se passe on sait pas c'est
vrai peut-être que j'ai vu des choses
que j'aurais jamais vécu ça à tous déjà
oublié une semaine pas six mois juste
pour voir ce qui se passe et tu t'amènes
un bon point le point de l'intuition moi
je trouve qu'il est fort sur arrive à
avoir le courage de t'ecouter et
d'entendre ça et de le faire ça je
trouve ça cool moi j'ai toujours suis
mon intuition
elle se bat pour mener à des endroits
magiques et et qui ramène à d'autres
endroits et quand tu imaginais pas
compris mais je sais pas quand sa magie
là mais c'est magie c'est une belle
rencontre c'est magique vivent ça c'est
cool tu vois j'ai dit le mot magique
mais ça au cou loin et en fait écouter
mon intuition ça a été une bonne chose
que j'ai apprise et je me rends compte
que c'est génial ça ça y est beaucoup
beaucoup de ceux qui comptent pour la
confiance que ton envers toi même de se
faire confiance parce que si tu fais pas
confiance de bonne confiance béton
envers toi même tu vas suivent beaucoup
plus les conseils des autres que ta
propre intuition
ouais moi j'ai beaucoup de choses
beaucoup déjà beaucoup décision que j'ai
prise dans ma carrière mon manager
fepaci pas bon pour toi mini-marché pas
ça sinon je sens champ que c'est bon tu
vois après coup bah oui j'ai eu raison
de le faire il ya plein de choses que je
m'habille pas faire et que j'ai fait et
finalement que j'ai adoré avoir fait
ouais
et ça ça découvrir des conseils que le
plus beau conseil que je peux donner
c'est écoute toi tout à la réponse à ce
que twitter
ils disent à steve jobs c'est le dernier
discours qu'il a fait en université
avant de mourir il est écouté votre
coeur il sait déjà ce qui serait la
bonne chose
un truc comme ça tu vois il dit moi je
me suis viré ma propre compagnie quêter
rapport où je vais travailler pour une
autre chose j'ai rencontré ma femme
bref il se rend compte que tu peux
finalement juste connecter les red hot
les points de ta vie quand tu regarde en
arrière je peux le faire en avant mais
il se rend compte que finalement il sait
écouter et tout le long il n'a pas
forcément eu le chemin qu'ils pensaient
qu'il allait avoir
mais finalement son chemin et s'est
avéré extraordinaire parce qu'il s'était
juste simplement écouter tu me fais je
trouve ça tu vois sim et écoutez moi je
vais pas me cette chemise là par exemple
mais ça pour dire que je pense que le
pouvoir de s'écouter et on l'a tous et
si on n'y a rien de mystérieux ya rien
de scientifique a rien de ces justes
s'écouter que la petite voix on a tout
eu la pépie c'est aussi un sommaire de
thé expérience
ouais c'est une fois tu es confronté à
une décision ou est une opportunité que
d'un filet mais que souvent le feeling
date de quelque chose que tu as vécu
avant ou que mettons un petit un petit
drapeau rouge qui j'ai des signes
avant-coureurs de problématique mais
souvent les gens font pas il faut passer
confiance acquis qu'ils étaient avant et
à leur expérience puis prennent malgré
tout une décision contre intuitive parce
que c'est dans l'oeil d'autres personnes
souvent la meilleure décision alors que
finalement la mairie sion pour eux est
s'arrêter de s'écouter oui carrément
c'est de se faire confiance et d'avoir
confiance en kit et ça revient ça
revient vraiment proche de comparer des
champions tantôt avec stanislas wawrinka
le résoudre le il s'écoute
ces gens là ils se font confiance à eux
plus qu'à mener pour qu'ils écoutent
leur coach ou c'est par exemple
ouais mais c'est leur coach dit quelque
chose qui va contre la réduction les
grands champions ils vont dire non c'est
sûr si les grands champions leur coach
l'ordi à et là tu devras tagué à gauche
que d'autres leur intuition principal
c'est non ils feront pas quand même
c'est ce qui fait que les plus grands
champions je suis persuadé le team est
trop faible pour reprendre son exemple
bob bowman son entraîneur il
il était vraiment bon pour faire un plan
d'entraînement puis de former son
athlète
mais celui qui corrigeait la technique
de michael phelps en premier c'est ma
confiance
c'est maintenant mais pourquoi tu sais
ce que michael phelps a amené le plus au
sport de la natation qui était en 2007
tu connais un petit peu la natation puis
peut-être que le monde qui nous écoutent
ont aucune idée de quoi je parle
mais dans le fond quand tu pousses du
mur à un virage au bout d'une longueur
le droit de passer quinze mètres sous
l'eau puis en 2007 michael phelps est
allé en poussant d'humeur il est allé
complètement en dessous de la surface de
l'eau il y avait eu du mal et un mètres
sous la surface nous est faite de batman
dauphin par 14 points 9 mike leigh est
sorti de l'eau comme ça plus personne ne
comprenait vraiment pourquoi il faisait
ça mais ça marche un crissement parce
que les gens se disaient ça va plus vite
danger exemple l'école qui trotte dow
jones alors que non mais personnes
comprenait pourquoi parce que
techniquement tu veux faire une ligne
droite située au pied du mur pète en
ligne droite plus qu'il faisait c'est un
arc vert en bois maintenant j'ai plus
longtemps que 50 ans comme ça alors puis
tout le monde dit qu'est ce que tu fais
pifano crise pourquoi ça marche comme ça
chez lui c'est son intuition les
personnes qui a appris ce
scientifiquement de pourquoi faire ceux
qui ont étudié après puis c'est que
quand quand et sous l'eau la résistance
dans les 50 premiers centimètres puis
quand tu vas sous les 50 centimètres de
plus de résistance et comme 30 % moins
de résistance dans l'eau mais l'huile
il leur reste sept de moins c'est le
plus grand nageur de tous les temps
c'est qu'il faisait sur les faisait ses
affaires c'est comme nom moi je le fais
vraiment comme ça et tout le monde fait
ça mais ça a été dur au lendemain et
l'année d'après être mon fils personne
ne faisait avec le même brio qui lui
l'avait fait mais tout le monde dise ça
ressorte plus grands champions d'un tel
centre et non de tous les temps et puis
personne qui va s'approcher de son
incroyable c'est parce qu'il avait
grandement il y avait un physique
de part son parfait pour tournage et y
avait le meilleur physique un humain
peut avoir pour faire il y avait tous
les facteurs il y avait 100% c'est à
toutes les télé crochets ico shelter
comme on dit entre la détermination le
fise est cette intuition le tous les
autres acteurs qui demandaient 30
athlètes cadets à ce niveau là c'est
gauche toute
c'est comme quand tu joues à sins tt tt
des points dans cette étude en
créativité tout et d'enfants font
référence aux sims ou team a perdu
construit les vrais les vrais faux pas
s'il ne mérite pas de respirer ça
c'était si tu joues pas facile à
s'écouler ya mais ouais fait que c'est
cool je chante que tu as envie de t'en
vite ouvrir à tout ça ouais ben may de
définitivement définitivement puis des
fois j'ai l'impression d'être un peu
dans une énorme vague qui est vraiment
plus grosse que toi puis classés à faire
que tu peux vraiment faire si un peu de
diriger leur vague pas vraiment le choix
de suivre la vague parce que parce que
sinon comme l'air de sortir de là c'est
la marne c'est parce que c'est une vague
qui passe une fois dans ta vie ce que tu
peux faire ce nom peut diriger mais au
moins son contrôle
c'est dire que ce métaphore du après
audi ouais ouais t'as fait que match en
double ouais ok ouais ça fait
à bali de 2 à 2 en mai mais c'est quand
même une grosse bague peut être pas
beaucoup de contrôles mais c'est quoi le
c'est quoi le le après rodez c'est quoi
le le positif et le bâclage positif
c'est que je suis suis en ce moment en
train de parler oui ce serait ça serait
jamais arrivé si si on était deux
personnes qui personne connaît qu'on
essaie de ce parti en podcast est
garanti que qu'on pourrait pas atteindre
les gens qu'on atteint rapidement puis
qu'on est capable de faire ça le négatif
c'est que j'avais beaucoup de monde et
demi mot même valait cher quand même
puis là je lis plus vraiment mais c'est
de moins en moins pour moi parce qu'une
fois que ça ça passe magique et les gens
oublient un peu à ça les gens oublient
pommes les gens m'en parlent moi des
gens qui te reconnaissent de plus en
plus c'est pour des raisons pour nos
forêts raison soit toujours extrêmement
kita et c'est à aude et on passe à autre
chose
elle a later this paulo alors pourquoi
ils te ait eu quelques effets de haïti
sable là que j'ai compris de me pourrait
mieux en parler de moi parce que lui
mais ça fait prison à madame dhalla
même moi de ma perception c'est que
c'est moi je fais une maîtrise en
littérature fait que des fois il faut
quand je parle puisqu'elle peut tantôt
plus expérimenté des fois ça me prend du
temps on arrivait à mon point vous jetez
chu l'enam et propre au pij m'exprime
somme toute bien puis pitou peu
d'émotion qui transparaît dans trois ans
je suis sûr exact exact que ça peut
paraître ben ça c'est ce que sa la pa
russell a paru vraiment comme si tp d'un
puits puis je me pensais au dessus des
gens avec qui j'étais
ce qui était somme toute un peu vrai
pour certains c'était un fonds de
quelque chose comme par exemple et c'est
ça tu dis je me suis cru au-dessus de
certains comme par exemple je pense que
tout le monde qui a écouté l'émission va
savoir de qui je parle principalement on
s'en sort pas un métier c'est que c'est
ça je pense que j'avais aussi j'ai aussi
puissent servir
encore au point principal d'une
confiance en moi que tu as et
inébranlable fait chic qu'est ce que je
vaux puis je m'en cache pas je ne vais
pas jouer faussement l'humilité car
quand j'ai pas l'impression que c'est
nécessaire c'est où j'ai pas
l'impression que ça va changer quoi que
ce soit a fait que j'ai pas quand je
crois quelque chose puis que je suis
cool persuadé même ce qui concerne
convaincre jouera pas fait ce que ça m'a
paru c'est que c'est que quand tu veux
faire un effort d'humilité c'est que ça
c'est de l'orgueil cacher tu vois c'est
qu'il montre ict orgueilleux mais en
fait non il y aura un mal à être
orgueilleux du pays à vouloir absolument
être humble qu'en fait tu n'as pas du
tout il est humble poissons sont là de
la fausse humilité et c'est encore pire
que de potes d'humilité ouais il était
bon pour rester jacques brel mais c'est
jacques brel le chanteur je lui dis
juste qu'ils pensaient il ya un mais
rien à [ __ ] de ce qu'on pouvait penser
lui ça mange envie ça il n'y avait pas
de chanteur français n'étaient pas
claires
ça fume est relatif il n'y avait pas de
qu'est ce que vous en pensez mais moi je
n'ai rien fait moi juste que j'ai envie
de dire qui fait 7 ème faire [ __ ]
s'étaient tus gainsbourg qui
sérieusement qui s'écoute plus bas
depuis à lui demande c'est quoi plus
beaucoup plus beau cadeau je n'ai jamais
donné ma queue y avait pas de match non
non non en fait il se crée des
personnages déclare ma super nature mais
que si j'allais ta performance la larme
à rome moi je pense que oui parce que
c'est ça qu'est ce qu'ils dégagent
oui moi je pense qu'ils remettaient
m'accuse
trop théâtral parce que les gens ont
aimé ça le vrai nom fait qu'ils aient
appuyé sur le fait que j'ai une chance
que je pense qu'ils sont sûrs c'est que
je veux je veux être jouer de vrais
jusqu'où cela gêne ce quelqu'un arrive
maintenant sur le plateau pénélope mais
les jeunes le vrai mais des fois c'est
dire de démâter devoir me fit le vrai
vrai du faux vrai ouais je suis d'accord
avec toi parce qu'on est bons à être
faux vrais faux vrais la force de citer
parce qu on est beaucoup à ça on vit
dans un monde beaucoup social ce avec un
masque et beaucoup et mettez un match à
un représentant de nous mêmes un
personne à personne pour se faire aimer
pour faire accepter et puis tu vois ça
on est bon là dedans je retrouve a été
élevé comme ça et ce qui fait que le
jour où tu veux enlever ce masque là est
vraiment vrai des fois même toi tu
arrives à te mentir non non j'ai été
vrai mais qu'en fait on en dessous il ya
autre chose tu vois c'est pas évident de
vouloir enlever ces masques là et de
prendre le risque d'arriver d'être aimé
parce que finalement ce match là ça va
ça sert à ce projet à se faire aimer les
gens et surtout dans un milieu public
ouais tu dis bonne chose de disques il
faut dire tu dis pour clientes
apprécient pour avoir du succès pour
étudie si j'enlève ce masque là bas les
gens vont arrêter de m'aimer mais
souvent cesser ces noms font 17 parle
bien sûr parce que parce que le vrai
vrai ça ça parait il une intuition chez
les gens qui quittent un 18-6 on est ici
ou alors mais qui nous y mais c'est vrai
qu'on aime se lever de vraies vérités
puis je pense que c'est toujours payant
d'être le plus vrai possible
ouais mais c'est plus dur ouais le
vulgaire mais ça fait du bien par
exemple qu'on commence à être réellement
vraiment honnête toujours si libérateur
avant tu vois je pensais sa définition
de la vraie paix ouais c'est d'être de
vrais c'est d'être complètement enlevé
ce match là c'est là où tu es libéré je
pensais sincèrement bien à ce moment là
ouais tu arrives à faire ça tu as plus
de ta plus de poids tapis de ses plus
lourd ses fusains m l'uem le pas et moi
je suis sa section c'est ça la vraie
mais je pense à définition de la pdm
pour moi c'est ça c'est complètement
soit mais ce passif puis après tout ça
veut pas dire d'arrêter d'essayer
s'améliorer d'être une meilleure
personne
mais fo si c'est ça accepter ce qu'on
est aujourd'hui en ce moment parce que
tu es j'ai eu aussi la difficulté avec
le discours bay à des machines même
faculté jamais tant qu'enquêteur
approche quelque chose des machines mais
non en fait
des fois c'est ça ce maillard ddg pas
l'intention d'essayer de m'améliorer
ça peut être ça peut être l'année où si
la main avec ça mais je pense pas qu'on
puisse reprendre ce que je dis on
s'améliorer tu veux pas changer ce que
tu es tu étais plein de choses autant
belle que moins belle tu peux par contre
choisi de ne pas les exprimer
mettons tous nos invités manipulateur ok
c'est le mari manipulateur non bah je
pense pas non non mais tu étais
manipulateur et c'est partie de toi tu
peux pas l'enlever
tu peux arrêter que le côté manipulateur
disparaît de toi parce qu' aucune
manière d'essayer de corriger des
d'amoindrir cette règle non tu peux
juste et décide pas l'exprimer
il faut dire et je me vois et
manipulateur pas je ne puis je pas être
ça moi je veux pas être un manipulateur
enfin tu dit juger ce prime passé par
teulet deux mois puis tu peux pas
l'enlever de toi comme un alcoolique qui
reste alcoolique mais qu'ils arrêtent de
boire kibo plus jamais mais j'ai
l'impression que tu peux modifier à la
longue à force de de ne plus être sûr
j'ai l'impression que tu peux te riquet
dans mon cerveau à ne plus lente devient
sur ammann et quand dans tes propres
comportements puis aussi dans le regard
de tous d'époque et typo certain d'une
chose les tue vraiment comme moi je
pensais pas encore partie de toi fils
culture est apte à rennes il l'exprimé
oublie moi j'veux pas être cet être
humain là je pattaya qui manipulent même
ça fait partie de moi mais tout fait
partie des douze enfants batouche
passion a toutes les qualités de tout le
monde pour qu'on a tous beaucoup de
qualités on a beaucoup de qualités des
fois en commun mais on n'a pas tous tout
je pense pas mais on a tous je suis pas
moins de 1000 milles qualités défauts
mais je crois pas qu'on puisse les les
enlever ne nous ont pas que tu puisses
quand on dit travailler sur nous et je
pense décide l'exprimer ou non mais tu
pourras pas le nom parce que quelque
chose se vend je suis un petit sourire
de toyal petit je sais pas ce que c'est
j'arrive pas déterminé ce que
il ya aucun jugement depuis le début
c'est de comprendre ce que ça c'est quoi
le sourire mais vraiment mais j'ai une
idée de question que je lui ai posé en
face aux demandes des fois j'ai des
choses que je te vois que des souris et
je me dis est-ce qu'il n'y croit pas et
ce qu'ils trouvent ça bizarre
non mais je suis le meilleur du jugement
justement ça m'intéresserait d'aller
voir ce qu'il ya dans ça mais la
question qui qui qui me les deux finales
tandis que demain ouais enfin bon c'est
ça on consulte pas peut pas enlever ça
c'est tout tu peux juste décide pas
exprimé sur le site où j'allais juste a
demandé toi jérémy c'est quoi aller les
choses qui décidait d'arrêter d'exprimer
tes défauts que tu vu pu exprimer un
message ces manipulateurs moi je suis un
manipulateur
moi je suis un très grand manipulerait
oui oui mais oui évidemment mais non
mais t'es avant gelée par contre je la
mets en relation amoureuse ou en
relation avec le public en général
un enfant de deux ans un manipulateur
moi j'ai conservé une fiche de voir deux
ans ben tu pleures tu es vraiment tu
vois qu'avec quelque chose à viens de
comprendre que quand je pleure j'ai
quelque chose vient comprend la
manipulation on est tous très fort là
dedans et je pense que des fois tu
m'avais plus le temps rend pas compte
tu dis une chose pour avoir quelque
chose d'autre tu dis un compliment pas
de l'amour en échange c'est quelque
chose parce que c'est qu'ils servaient
stratégique face à la manipulation
et moi je la vois chez dc les dizaines
de gens moi j'suis manipulateur en
général avec ma blonde avec le public
avec mes amis je suis animateur mais
mais c'est pas négatif net manipulateur
souvent on voit des mots puis on se dit
c'est manu c'est négatif je prends ton
dieu chez un violeur est en train de
dire que c'est quand même andy est allé
vite ça peut être une qualité des fois
manipulé pour quelque chose de bien ça
peut être ça peut être bien mais dont la
mettons là quelqu'un braque une banque
c'est moi qu'il faut qu'ils qui la
paient pour négocier bon si jamais
encore arrivé mais maintenant ça juste
pour des trucs qui ne bénéficia moi si
ça arrive il va disséquer le plus grand
manipulateur au québec
gérer les a mais on va l'appeler non
mais c'est juste que des fois je me vois
être saude fois ma blonde me remarque
est en train de manipuler
ah oui c'est vrai déjà rien mais l'effet
capable de nommer c'est quand même
beaucoup chemin parcouru il parcourut
parce que les plus grands manipulateurs
ont toujours nier le m way pourtant tu
vois c'est évident moyens les plus les
plus grasses et
on le voit tous souhaitent mais ils vont
jamais vu ça des fois c'est pas on voit
ça négatif mais des fois c'est tes amis
et ta blonde avec avec sais c'est pas
forcément négatif en est manipulateur tu
peux être manipulateur pas méchant ça
peut être on pas entre nous puis
j'arrive à faire quelque chose où je
vais avoir raison donc je dis quelque
chose pour qui sait quelque chose
puisque voilà je n'ai jamais été
manipulé rien de tu vois d'absolument
méchant ou négatifs ou condamnable c'est
juste une qualité ou un défaut comme un
autre jeune et plein je suis impulsif
des fois je suis très rationnelle des
fois que complètement rouge des fois je
suis des fois je sens les choses se font
dans quelque chose sans s'en faire
grille a pas griot blanc moyen-moyen
yahia blanc ou noir
j'ai pas lyon c'est ça qui est plein de
choses comme ça des fois je suis très
égocentrique
j'en ai un million de choses comme ça et
puis après c'est ce que je veux ou pas
être cette personne là si la réponse est
non alors j'arrête de l'exprimer
si la réponse est oui alors venez
j'utilise et des fois j'aimerais
utiliser la manipulation il faut 1 me
sert pour reprendre les choses et je
suis bon là dedans et ben pourquoi pas
des fois je le nomme tu vois lâcheté
manipuler commun c'est sincère c'est
clair c'est moi je le reconnais temps je
ne mens pas à moi tu vois mentir aux
autres j'ai encore le droit des fois je
m'enterre une fois je mens autres qui
ment pas alors là qui n'a jamais menti
les gars qui n'a jamais menti personne
donc des fois chanteur mais au moins moi
je sais que je mens je me le dit la
chanson entière là je suis vraiment
vraiment fière avec moi à moi je ne mens
pas je manque encore au d'autres mais à
moi je veux dire la gt tu vois et si au
moins j'avais à me dire la vérité à moi
s'il arrive à dire moi je ne trahirai
plus moi c'est déjà un bon début tu vois
après j'ai droit de manipuler le droit
de te mentir je vois ce que je haïs mais
ne t'en fais pas de mal et que mais j'ai
envie de me dire la vérité à moins un
maximum j'ai envie d'être conscient en
fait ce concept c'est un peu comme le
véganisme c'est à dire j'arrête de
manger de la viande c'est vraiment
devenir conscient c'est ça et plus
conscients ou inconscients de ce que je
mange ce que je dis de ce que je fais
prisa qu'ancien prise de conscience
c'est ça finalement
la sagesse que n'importe quel être
humain prend en vieillissant et réalisé
ce que je suis autant dans le beau dans
le moins bon c'est juste devenir plus
conscience de tous et je pense que plus
tu arrives à accepter toutes les parties
de toit plus plus la ville bien simple
pas pourquoi parce que celle testée en
oui il ya le dire la hem toi lafosse
aimer mais je crois pas moi le terme
fossé mais je le comprends pas
aujourd'hui ça veut rien dire c'est mais
pour moi
on peut aimer si je dis aime moi que tu
vas faire n'a pas de nom mais même table
ont dit - mouais moi dire quoi tu le
faire un câlin une caresse mais je dire
clairement exprimé celui de l'amour où
c'est la tendresse
ces deux là ont fusé l'affection
physique tu vois est moins tu vas faire
une blague et bref la vertu de l'amour
ou c'est des symboles de quelque chose
que tu vois c'est que la blanche a dit m
mois de tabac veut dire que mon école -
ouais mais aime moi si tu peux pas
forcer seul ne peut pas demander ce oui
c'est ça fait l'idée faussé mais moi j'y
crois pas par contre s'accepter accepter
toutes les parties de loin ça c'est une
vie qui est clair qu est que n'importe
qui peut comprendre et qu'on peut faire
tu vois c'est diriger çà çà çà çà
j'accepte de ça chez moi après sa page
de garde ne veut dire je décide ou non
de l'exprimer mais je suis ça et je
pense qu'on peut tous ici de voir 55 des
faucons à tous trois tu vois en général
même ce qui est magique là dedans c'est
ce que tu vois chez les autres tu lâches
étroits en général souvent ceux qui te
dérange chez les autres parce que tu le
toit ouais c'est un peu le principe des
reins chez toi aussi
ouais mais je n'ai pas encore reconnu
chez toi qu'il fait chier je sais que tu
sais tu lâches et toi fait que c'est
facile de se connaître en fait nos
parents on est comme nos parents non moi
j'ai pas comme mes parents non
exactement comme tes parents souvent
souvent la tat beaucoup beaucoup de
choses que tes parents tu as aussi et
c'est de là qu'il nous fait chier chez
nos parents souvent c'est parce qu'on
est comme finalement et et voilà et ça
je trouve que ce processus là moi il est
intéressant
apprendre à se connaître et à voir
comment réagit comment ce qu'on est
je trouve ça je trouve ça cool parce que
du coup après tu vis plus de situations
qui te met dans une situation de marais
des situations où ou des fois tu aurais
pu dire pourquoi je vais j'ai vécu ça à
parce que j'étais manipulateur mais je
m'en suis pas rendu compte
si tu sais que les manipulateurs trapu a
vu des situations où on manipule ce que
tu sais que les manipulateurs texas est
finie et tu vas pouvoir vivre une vie
france + plus légères parce qu'on disait
tout à l'heure la paix vient quand tu
quand on enlève ton masque et tu fais
juste admettre ce que t elle tout
simplement l'ayant est facile quand on a
soi-même systermans fondamentale en fait
très soi même est capable de reconnaître
ses qualités ses défauts
ce qu'on a travaillé ce compte tout ce
ce conte
veut nous besoin d'eux et c'est la chose
la plus importante ouais et dur à faire
être honnête envers soi et admettre que
t'es plein de va dire aux gens en toi tu
es un menteur tintin un voleur non non
les gens vont réagir
on est tous des menteurs ou tous des
voleurs qui n'a jamais volé rien 1 deux
piasses un stylo une gomme du temps à
quelqu'un qui n'a jamais volé de temps
quelqu'un personne un film dans l'aude
illégal a fait mander illégalement qui
coupa fait qu'on est tous des voleurs
ouais bah tous il va gérer la sq a
forcément que moi ça mais on est tous
des menteurs des voleurs des études des
manipulateurs des pièces pas grave on a
rien à [ __ ]
on est ça et alors que ça peut faire
tant que ça pas blesser les gens où on
et ça c'est tout et puis enlever ces
masques sociale là et arrêtées dès qu'on
est juste beau sympathique et généreux
et arrêter de se mentir sur quelque
chose de cool là dedans tu vois je pense
pas qu'une différence en dire on est et
on est tous voleurs et on a tous déjà
volé je pense pas qu'une différence
voilà les deux sites à voler et et
voleurs n'ont battu polar ça sonne comme
un trait de caractère volée je comprend
quelque chose qui est qui qui se
pratique qui n'est pas parce que tu
apprécies cet avis beaucoup qui était
aujourd'hui encore un menteur je
comprends cette défaite des filles je
comprends tu as raison je pense que même
si tu m'as encore de façon sporadique
mais de façon sporadique têtu un
maintenant je comprends ce que tu veux
dire moi c'était très mal exprimé
parce qu'une partie de toi qui es ouais
t'es capable de le faire tu es capable
farceur définitivement ok on peut dire
ayez une partie des cadres de maintien
de mentir grave devant d'hier étaient
capables de voler avec une partie de toi
lui laissa aller minime mais elle est là
ça suscitait plus ouais de dire que
c'est exact est un menteur tu es tête
passa une partie de toi il passe moi qui
ai mon terrain une partie de moins qu'un
voleur rien partie de moi que tu vois là
je faisais partie de nous qu'on met de
l'avant
puis on m'a emmené à l'argent va être
épique on veut être lesquels on laisse
de côté et qui va exactement toutes ses
salles à s'améliorer si je pense que ces
deux côtés celle que tu veux plus mais
même si je dis moi dans ma vie moi je
veux être un manipulateur et un voleur
c'est comme ça que je ma vie et alors
que ça peut se faire des passes à la loi
- tu es honnête tel droit métier je
pense que le team en une vie bones une
vie justement qui fait pas de mal aux
gens autour de toi puis la manipulation
et le vol et tous ceux sakho souvent mal
à autrui
moi je pense que genre des qualités
défauts peu importe ce que tu décides de
fois dans ta vie peu importe genre
générer un trip the world
j'en ai rien à crisser du moment où est
ce que tu sais pas de mal aux gens
autour de toi toi puis c'est ce play
manipulation et le mensonge sont souvent
ont souvent ses conséquences le nom est
lui même de faux je manipule des genres
a aucune conséquence et mensonges à la
pâte ou le mensonge peut même avoir des
conséquences les mensonges la
conséquence que ça va puis la personne
sarmento compte c'est que si tu dit pas
la vérité aussi cacher était quelqu'un
tu l'empêchent de prendre une décision
éclairée avec les bonnes informations
si tu caches une information à table on
nous situe juste un petit mensonge à
quelqu'un pourra retirer quelque chose
cette personne-là ont pas pu prendre le
faire le choix par rapport à la vérité
objective ou des factures liées à
enlever cette liberté d'enlever la
liberté à quelqu'un
d'abord la pleine connaissance sur une
situation bien que tu dis bagis démenti
là dessus c'est l'anti exclusive tout
démenti qu'il ait menti
moi je 100% en est à chaque fois que je
mange le dit non mais tu sais tu as
raison je suis d'accord pas d'accord
devant ce oui la manipulation peut faire
mal ou bien failli finir par a aucune
conséquence si en tant qu il aurait su
dès ce soir vous est il le meilleur
public de toute ma carrière c'est un
mensonge et de la manipulation des
régions étudiées après on enfile issa
hier aussi
cativen l'armement mentir les manipuler
et en voitures a dit la vérité et à
blesser personne mais se passe tu calmes
a mené à la longue
les gens peuvent le fleuriste maintenant
si tu le dis ouais ok j j les joueuses
et manipulé là je vous ai vu le crosseur
en moins à la paf tu as vu ça j'ai passé
ça comme si rien n'était et tu leur dis
que tu viens de le faire c'est qu'il ya
plus de temps 30e démasquer tous seuls
ils ont pu être démasqué étude des
masses tout seul tu vois le truc moi je
comprends tu faisais melliger démarre
encore une fois démenti comme comme slim
shady là le film qui a fait un mal fou à
la fin il dit tout sur lui il dénonce tu
vois je sache sache ça maintenant
valider quelque chose que les gens
savent pas sur moi mais il ya un peu ça
tu peut démentir tout en disant là j'ai
fait ça et voilà alors tu vas tu fais
que tu enlève ton masque je suis dit
voilà j'ai été honnête en vous montrant
que je vous ai menti fort mal ça quand
même comme un métier mais dans une
situation où j'aime entrer une histoire
de toutes pièces dont je vais vous
prendre comme exemple
mais admettons le un monde où l'histoire
que ton père est mort que ta vie 8 ans
était une invention de toutes pièces
mais c'est certainement une histoire ou
six pilotes utilisent cette histoire
mettant dans nos spectacles pour toucher
les gens qui est écrit dans son livre
petit sopi puis vraiment ça affecte une
histoire particulière ça fait quelque
chose à dirigeante écoute les gens sont
touchés par une histoire ce pilote tout
dit tout rationaliser en disant oui mais
peu importe ici vrais pauvres et les
gens sont touchés ça fait réfléchir les
gens ça fait grandir les gens donc pas
vraiment important si c'est vrai ou non
n'empêche qu'ils aient si jamais les
gens apprennent que c'est un ramassis de
foutaises
c'était pas vrai ça se peut qu'ils
soient irrités s'explique soient forcés
à bray toi parce que tout accord même
capitaliser sur la dessus sur quelque
chose qui était qui était faux allawi
s'est appuyé sur un mensonge et qu'on le
découvre c'est et déjà vers touba
tu as joué au jeu puis tu as perdu
examen là bien sûr ça fait incorrect
parce que d'ailleurs non plus sa
confession à c'est une confession à mon
père va très bien il fait bon jouer
il a le talent d'ici
monsieur jean le malaise je suis
d'accord avec toi si tu capitalise sur
un gros mensonge quinze jours durant des
coûts que c'est pas vrai bah c'est un
suicide social comme la chef le polo oui
la jeune millionnaire
oui la gêne il y en a aussi qui permet
les les conseillers de ben oui c'était
un genre des conseillers qui était posée
spécialistes un chemin près c'était quoi
le dos il faut vraiment station de la
foutaise comme étant un expert mais tu
vois avec plein d'exemples salvail n'en
avait une image de sang
joël legendre tout le monde a dans
l'inconscient collectif le temps était
parfait
le gars homosexuel assumé deux enfants
oui les pots de jeunes de 22 ans
végétarien du poteau et personne non
plus non et puis je dire les madame
qu'on a pris ce à quoi alors que
pourtant oui quoi il est humain oui
alain bombard on est sûr c'est que
qu'est-ce qu'ils s'amendent quoi ça
montre qu'on montre une belle image de
ma chambre
on a un beau masque bien polis enlève ça
c'est moins beau derrière tu vois la
côte en bas après gipa faut aller le
dire j pas vrai dans la vie moi j'aime
ça quand et par qui me touchent et la
bise ou pas forcément ce qu'il a à faire
non plus c'est juste que ya toute
atteinte est à dire que je n'ai pas
juste des belles personnes
on y est on est tous tout le monde et
tous finalement tu vois c'est être prêt
à laisser transparaître les côtés - bout
de toi un public sur scène ou à utiliser
en dessous j'ai j'ai envie tu vois j'ai
envie de le faire j'ai envie de te dire
que j'ai une partie de moi qui est
manipulateur il ya quatre ans j'aurais
jamais dit ça d'une parce que je l'aï
jamais vu chez moi ouais et de deux
parce que je me serais dit à dire ça tu
imagine ce que je peux perdre
et puis finalement je me disais
on est tous eu plein de choses donc j'ai
envie de dire un maximum je vois pas qui
à tous qui se dit ouais parce qu'il ya
des choses qu'on a gardé pour nous deux
qui mérite d'être nettement pas tout
mais dire que je pas parfait que voilà
que quelques cons et humain je trouve
que c'est vers là où fois au fauteuil tu
vois
ouais c'est ça c'est et puis admettre tu
vois admettre que coûte fait une erreur
on prend la main dans le sac bah oui tu
dis j'ai fait j'ai fait j'ai fait une
erreur
et puis voilà il ya eu une histoire avec
avec gad elmaleh dernièrement c'est
comme qui l'avait plongé tout ça moi
j'écoutais ça puis j'ai vu la vidéo puis
je me suis dit c'est peut-être le moment
deuxièmement ouais j'ai merdé quoi j'ai
merdé
peu importe la raison j'ai eu peur de ne
pas réussir à créer je sais pas j'ai
aimé sa jeunesse nomades peu importe la
raison
j'ai merdé et à l'occasion à ce moment
là avec quelqu'un d'honnête honnête j'ai
merdé excusé j'ai merdé les gens trois
jours après on oublié parce que
finalement tu as pas tuer personne n'a
pas violé personne n'a pas séquestrés
bon avec je skie pas correct mais pas de
là te mettre en prison pendant dix ans
tu vois donc tu le dis puis voilà c'est
fini dit sa réponse était d'envoyer
promener ses détracteurs ben ouais je
pensais après il l'a reconnu il a connu
une partie gatsby si ces courageux mais
moi je pense quand j'ai vu ça je le suis
bazille admet le pire à dealer way soit
ce tome la vie on en parlera plus fait
qu'on en parle encore parce que
justement tu n'as pas voulu l'admettre
est juste le dire
puis c'est fini tu vois puis après ses
débuts fait le plus c'est le puppy tu
vois justement j'avais entendu rachid
qui est venu sur votre podcast comme ça
que j'ai découvert ça qui s'est dit
c'est dit voilà moi j'ai merdé
il ya quelques années j'étais un peu
arrogant je fais si je fais ça génial tu
viens de dire que ta merde et c'est fait
j'ai merdé je reconnais je m'excuse
maintenant je veux devenir une personne
plus plus cool
ben voilà qui n'a jamais merde et qui
n'as tu vois c'est ces sacs icool je
trouve c'est de se dire dans on est
humains finalement effectivement puis
mais c'est ça mais se fait par d'années
il faut que toi même
bah oui à deux états tu te repenti
satisfait j'ai merdé et puis après tu
auras tu pas m'aimer mais au moins vous
nagez j'ai été honnête chili a hérité je
trouve ça beau à amy tu vois d'enlever
ce truc-là d'arrêter de faire semblant
pas facile parce qu'on a on a grandi en
disant si je suis gentil je suis sympa
je suis machin je me faire aimer c'est
comme ça qu'on a été éduqué sois gentil
91 pour mériter l'amour de nos parents
fallait être gentil il fallait avoir des
bonnes notes fallait être sage fallait
pas parler fort tu vois c'est là où ne
pas renouer mais si on criait qu'on est
pas des menottes de l'inconscient
engueuler qu'on a appris avec les bonnes
personnes
on a appris à se faire aimer en temps
des bonnes personnes alors qu'on n'est
pas des bonnes personnes on est des
êtres humains avec du beau et du
beau et je pense que c'est en montrant
les deux camps qu'on découvre la paix en
disant je suis des fois celle de la
personne des fois je suis moins beau et
je m'excuse quand je suis moins bon mais
des fois ça m'arrive je trouve ça cool
plus léger surtout être dans dans le
showbiz je pense
la vulnérabilité c'est la clé de
l'invulnérabilité tu cherches la
vulnérabilité
c'est la clé de l'invulnérabilité parce
qu'une fois tu as tout dit il ne peut
rien dire sur toi tu as vingt six ans
maintenant
vas-y j'aimerais en faire j'ai tout dit
ou fait je te montre et je suis
intouchable c'est pas moi je dis ouais
quand même
bah ouais puis c'est même plus une
histoire de gym faire coincer ou passé
voici ce que je suis et moi et moi pas
qu'est ce que tu veux toi mais voici ce
que je suis tu vois voici le menu après
alors être pas les mêmes j'avais un truc
super conversation merci les gars avec
son spectacle j'ai je termine ma tournée
fin janvier et ensuite en veulent plus
de toi qu'est-ce qui se passe
s'ils veulent plus de moi j'habite au
nom j'ai un facebook j'ai instagram et
beaucoup donné et voilà et puis et puis
et puis voilà
qu'est ce que je peux vous dire d'autre
je sais pas si c'est des choses à plat
guessan on met les gens qui veulent se
renseigne un show puis j'ai deux trois
petits livres que j'ai écrits comme ça
en mettant ses rides qui se vend un peu
partout
sandra car dans les tops de renaud bray
jeu calée au renault est en fait chaque
fois la pilule alli socialiste c'est
magique ça j'ai vu le j'ai vu en
arrivant ici j'ai subtilement les c'est
rare mais ça tu vois ça a été une
aventure magique parce que il ya cinq
ans mais je m'intéresse à ce sujet là et
je suis sur la plage jeudi j'ai envie
d'écrire à dieu genre 24 m'en fous je
vais écrire vendu un petit peu plus les
cartes à jour 2 2 4 avant un phénomène
et mais tu vois ces parties de gens vous
décrivent une intuition ont décrit après
tout je fais vas-y on essaye bien les
seuils et je les fais et puis c'est
devenu quelque chose de magique ça pour
moi c'est magique ce que t'es pas
auteurs ne considère pas un auteur un en
écrivant en fait chez auteurs suis pas
écrivain
tu vois un écrivain c'est vraiment
quelqu'un de sensé et c'est écrit des
romans et un auteur c'est un gars qui va
écrire n'importe qui peut être auteur et
à limiter à gagner sa vie avec mes et
c'est devenu magique parce que souvent
le seul lieu et puis souvent encore
d'ailleurs ils vont encore quatre ans
plus tard mais ça montre que c'est juste
quoi c'est juste de la je me suis écouté
et j'ai fait un truc que j'ai jamais
fait avant et puis et puis voilà puis ça
a fonctionné
c'est cool et puis voilà puis de melgven
que qu'est ce qu'on souhaite 2020 je
vais avoir un bébé tu vas avoir le c est
en cours sa route sans route au centre
en cuir il faut pas faire grand chose
jusqu'à 2 3 minutes est venu une fois
devenu une fois je vais avoir une petite
fille et donc je vais être papa
et puis après je vais l'essayer
je laissais la france ah ouais ouais
jamais voulu c'est un peu un aubry n'est
en fait pas tant non pas tant que ça tu
vois pas ce que ça fait 15 ans que je
suis ici et je pense j'ai passé treize
ans avant me disant jamais joué en
france et ça c'est rentré dans mon
esprit et quelques années il fait il ya
deux ans c'est pourquoi pas pourquoi pas
je suis allé faire de 3s est très
anxieux là bas en dix ans peut-être que
j'arrive à jamais et finalement à chaque
fois que j'y vais ça se passe super bien
et vous jouez jamais faire l'expérience
de tout en restant ici je suis pas avant
mais le québec je suis faire sûrement
moitié moitié
mais je veux aller essayer je veux
l'expérimenté là bas voir ce qui se
passe non c'est que ces gens si les gan
merci beaucoup merci à vous les boys
c'est un plaisir